Lely uh good evening welcome to this
evening's uh planning committee West my
name is Justin Carriage I'm the chair uh
in front of me uh are the other
counselors who are members of the
committee to my left and right are
offices of this Council and uh County
Council who will help us make our
decisions today and if I can ask them to
introduce themselves Caroline Mash
committee
administrator Ross Chambers Legal
Services
my name is David Jeffrey I'm the Weston
team leader in my role as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise doing so
I am Bound by the code of professional
conduct conduct of the royal town
planning Institute planning committee
members are not bound by the case
officer's recommendation or by Oral
advice Victoria chadow senior
planner uh Ben Sim wer County Council
highways Louise kman kman senior
planner Charlotte dicks planning
officer stti planning
officer that's great and we'll go
straight to the agenda uh number one
apologies for absence non received great
um any disclosures of Interest councelor
organ thank you chairman with regard to
Applications 18025 582 and 1802
639 I objected to the outline
application but the reserved matters
applications are only concerned with
matters of detail not the principle of
the development which has already been
approved as such I'm satisfied that I
can take part in the consideration of
the application and have come to the
meeting with an open mind about
considering these applications thank you
thank you for that councelor thank you
same application I have had
correspondence from members of the
residence Action Group both email and a
phone call but again I'm here with an
open mind and happy to to remain on on
the committee um on
48141 ful uh Langley Road I'm the W
member there um I haven't made any form
of representation and I'm here with an
open mind so I'll continue to sit on the
on the committee okay I think we've all
received a lot of well I've certainly
received a lot of uh information uh and
emails from I think the Town Council and
the war board member um on the Arden
Heath Farm application so that that's is
that all members yes I think so
counselor
2046 bragon I should be speaking as the
ward member okay thank you and now
um minutes minutes of the last meeting
uh are we okay to pass
those no one says no yes lovely thank
you uh so those are agreed uh now
instead of going to four I would like to
bring
forward
um application
number five which is
1800777 stroke4 Rainbow nurseries wford
Hill longm Road because I see in the
update sheet that the ward member has
withdrawn an objection and I think the
parish council have withdrawn the
objection as so can we bring that
forward I didn't object oh you didn't
object okay sorry about that we've been
negotiating as he said for some time
we've come to a satisfactory agreement
oh well that's nice to know uh so if we
can deal with that I'm suggesting that
we uh delegate that decision to officers
as there's no longer the parish council
objecting are we all agreed on that
agreed great lovely so thank you
Louise uh so now we can go to what is
item four on the agenda application 18
02582 and 1802
639 uh Reserve matters Arden Heath
farm and Victoria chadway will be
telling us something about
that
okay
lovely that was thank you thank you
chairman uh updates have been provided
for you in your update papers um this
presentation relates to two Reserve
matter applications submitted pursuant
to the outline consent referenced
14262 oblique o
which was allowed at a pill for up to
270 dwellings at Arden Heath Farm the
location of the site is indicated by the
black dot on the
screen this slide shows the outline
boundary of the entirety of the outline
site the site is located at the edge of
Stratford and is dissected by the Loxley
Road get the cursor to move here uh so
therefore has a parcel to the north and
a parcel of land to the south of the
road
this is a Google image of the site to
give more context um clearly you can see
that the site is at the existing edge of
Stratford um there is the golf club to
the northwest corner uh further to the
north we have tiddington the um football
club and the school uh and quite clearly
open fields surrounding its perimeter
with a a significantly more builtup area
within the builtup area of Stratford as
existing this is a plan that was
submitted at outline stage um an
indicative master plan for for the site
which uh indicated the the level of
development that could be achieved on
the site which helped to set the
parameters that then went forward it
shows connectivity through the site from
an existing footpath uh from wooden
close um the existing public foot path
comes to the bottom of the site uh and
shows that there would be an area for
public open space to the north including
the tenation Basin public open space in
this location and uh areas of um
landscape buffer surrounding the
site following the M indicative master
plan the outline was um conditioned uh
in relation to this plan here which is a
parameters plan which very clearly set
areas in which development should
shouldn't occur so the green areas as
I'm trying to indicate with my cursor
relate to um landscape buffers within
which no housing is
allowed uh the lighter green areas are
where the open space was proposed
including two areas for um play space
and then the sort of grayer brownie
areas are the areas where housing was
allowed and within those housing areas
there's um areas of height permitted for
proposed housing taken into account
Contours in the land so that set the
parameter that then had to come forward
with regards to reserve
matters one of the 28 conditions that
was imposed at outline stage um related
to the phasing of the delivery of houses
at Reserve matters stage and that had to
be submitted prior to um the submission
of any reserve matters
application uh at the time that it was
submitted there was one known developer
for the site um um and it was considered
that that this area in red which is the
phase two Housing Development that's
before you would come forward as phase
two phase one relates to drainage which
is being dealt with separately and phase
three is to do with the green
infrastructure so all of those green
areas that we saw on the previous plan
uh and and that's also a matter that's
before you now so you're looking at
phase two and three together but I'll go
into that in more detail as we go
through the
presentation so this is the redline
bower for the phase 2 Housing
Development for up to
135 um dwell or for 135 dwelling houses
and it relates to planning application
reference 18 oblique
02582 oblique
RM the red line boundaries obviously
within the wider blue line for the site
the matters reserved from outline um are
layout scale sorry layout scale
appearance and Landscape in and the
other matters that were specifically
defined by conditions and the outline
application this is the redline boundary
slightly more all over the place just
due to the nature of the green
infrastructure for the green
infrastructure proposal this is for the
phase three green infrastructure and the
application referen is 18 obli 02 639
oblique
R so this is um an over overall plan in
showing both Phase 2 and phase three um
within
context the bejer areas relate to phases
four and five which have recently been
submitted under a separate planning
application but are not for
consideration um at this
meeting this just shows a general um
layout and design for the proposal so
the H housing is to the south of the
site the access was agreed at outline
stage coming off the Loxley Road and the
principal proposal is for development
off of spy mode into the site and we'll
get into that more as we go through it
but we'll deal with um Landscaping
details first I appreciate that this
site is impossible to read um but it's
quite difficult to show all of the
details for for the green infrastructure
so fundamentally this was the overall
layout plan and each of these smaller
squares with a number on it relates to a
far more detail plan for that section of
the site and within each of those
proposed plans if you can see these
little boxes they relate to part of the
um planting and it shows the the species
that propos the percentage of that
species and details of of what's being
proposed in each bit so as two examples
this is um an extract from plan number
six which is adjacent to the golf club
um this sort of shows that the shrub
area and these are the species proposed
within it uh these are existing trees
that are be to be retained uh and then
grass areas
this is uh plan two which is for the
landscape buffer in the southwest corner
adjacent to W and close so we have the
existing footpath
here uh which will go to the other side
of the buffer zone and in this
particular area there's a small path
that's being um proposed within that
buffer in order to get onto the footpath
there are incidentally other paths in a
in a landscape bu of adjacent to um kns
Lane as
well part of the infrastructure plan was
for the creation of um play Space um two
two Parcels have been proposed one in
the north one in the South that would be
available to both existing and proposed
residents uh these have followed a more
natural play um
philosophy relating to the housing
layout so the phase 2 housing scheme
this is the overall layout plan again
here's the access this is the main
principal Road into the street which has
been proposed as a Treeline Street um
and then following in a hierarchy from
that following basic um design
principles
um let's go into it's worth noting at
this point just outside of the
application site there is an existing
private track which leads then into the
complex of the farm that's always been
outside of the the red line boundary and
does create an intersection between the
proposed road going into the farm and
specific details have been provided of
that Junction which are currently
subject to a road safety audit stage
one the car uh in considering the
character in the development of the
scheme the developer has considered that
there's three specific character areas
to to the this Southern parcel of land
with um a specific character from the
Loxley Road uh specific character to
dwellings that would be fronting onto
public open space and another character
again uh relating to the houses more
within within the middle of the
site
um this is showing some Street Scenes
from some of those sections so this is
the street seen from the Loxley Road
these are existing houses on the Loxley
Road these are not part of the
consideration of this application but
are indicative of what has been
submitted in phase four um uh by another
developer and then these would be the
houses that are proposed as part of
phase two looking out onto the open
space we have a very similar house types
but with different typologies to them um
trying to make reference to the more
rural location and then these are the
sort of tighter grain houses proposed on
the Main Street within the scheme as an
example of some of the differences that
have been brought out uh in looking at
the house types uh the blue circle is an
indication of this house type Ty um
that's proposed in this particular
location uh it proposes some design
features um so um sort of Ren rendered
Frontage um barge board details um and
detailing over the window exactly the
same house type but with alternative
details facing onto the public open
space uh with with a difference of
detail that Eaves and detailing along
sort of the sides of of the fronting um
Gable ends and the same house type again
but within the tighter grain of the
development and again subtle differences
but to reflect those character changes
within the scheme the Loy Road itself uh
is um obviously going to lead in into
this site and so um some consideration
has been given to um house types that
exist there and there is a a genuine
diversity of house types along the the
loxo these are some examples some have
hip roofs some have a bungalows some
have Gable frontages some have bay
windows some don't have bay windows some
have stone detailing uh some have barge
boards some have render
um so there's no in my view specific
character type to follow through uh and
then lastly this is um a view leading
into the site the north of the site
which is not apart from for the green
infrastructure for consideration here
and the southern element of the site as
viewed from the Loxy Road thank you
chair the recommendation
for um the first application which is
the phase two scheme for 135 houses um
is um to subject to a stage one road
safety audit being submitted in
consultation with the highways Authority
and agreed with the uh um the chair of
planning committee is to Grant Subject
to a number of conditions and in
relation to the second
application which is uh Reserve matters
for the group infrastructure the
recommendation is to Grant Subject to
conditions thank
you thank you very much
now I've got that we're going to listen
to this in in two bits but we're
actually not uh we're going to hear from
speakers now um uh on both applications
the one for the housing and the one for
the for the Landscaping uh all at the
same time but I think we've got to bear
bear in mind that there are two
applications before us those two so if
we first hear from the Town Council and
that's Jenny fagley for Stratford on aen
Town Council who has six minutes if you
wish
[Music]
it uh thank you CH I'm I'm sitting in
for um my husband who's actually chair
of the Town Council but he's unavailable
this evening so um I hope that I will do
the time Justice in his
place I probably won't take six
minutes um the town accepts uh that
outline planning permission is granted
for this development and that
development will take place but it
insists that policies in the uh
neighborhood design uh plan must be part
of considerations leading to this and
any further
applications there have been some
communication today rehousing mix when
it should was should be
decided I understand that an appeal
ruling earlier this year stated that
housing mix should be decided at outline
but in this case the appeals officer um
did not Define housing mix so I assume
it was to be decided by uh statford
District sorry statford District Council
without proper reference to the uh
NDP in fact on page 14 statford district
council dismisses the NDP as being
prescriptive this does not give
confidence to turns and parishes in the
district that the hard
work I'm sorry I'm I'm terribly sorry
I'm reading from the wrong script I I've
made several today and that's that's a
wrong script may I start
again I've got six minutes I mean I get
this in in six minutes come on then
start
and I refer to some of those things
anyway terribly sorry about that it
sounded very relevant but there we are
this is even more
relevant um the Town Council accepts
blah blah uh there has been
communication today concerning the
housing mix
numbers Arden Heath Farm was permitted
in outline three years ago I understand
to the very day at this time housing mix
was an issue for determination at the
reserved matter stage and as such such
was not defined by the inspector at the
time there has been an appeal decision
earlier this year when an appeals
inspector said that housing mix should
be decided at the outline stage this was
a decision by an appeals inspector and
is not case law legislation or
regulation but as I understand an
opinion as housing mix was not defined
an outline at appeal 3 years ago it
seemed a fair assump ion that it should
be decided at deferred matters where the
decision is made in accordance with
previous practice and up toate date
guidance that is the recently approved
statford on aen uh neighborhood um
development plan referendum on the 29th
of
November my understanding is that the
NDP has gained full weight as soon as a
referendum is approved by a majority of
Voters and government legislation of
some two years ago to prevent tardiness
in and uh ndps being made by local
counselors uh put this into
legislation it appears from page 14 in
the planning document planning West uh
the 5th of December that a decision has
been made by The District Council and
housing mix according to the core
strategy and a claim is being made that
that is now law and cannot be re
Revisited as it should have been defined
at at at outline
the housing mix ratio has been fixed by
SDC some two years after the outline
permission to make matters of more
concern on page 14 SDC say that the
higher core strategy figures have been
applied so that this scheme would
achieve cs19 on housing mix the lower
limit for one bed and the higher limit
for four bed units and as such would not
meet the more prescriptive H7 n DP
policy the NDP team commissioned a
housing consultation to ascertain the
needs of the town and the figures do
differ from the core strategy and were
defined to meet the specific needs of
the town the town council is adamant
that these figures should have had an
influence on the mix proposed rather
than being dismissed as
prescriptive if this approach is to be
taken about ndps then all the hard work
done by communities across the district
would have been for
nothing I apologize for concentrating on
one aspect of the Town council's concern
but I'm sure residents and Ward
counselors will bring up the other
issues to your attention I would urge
this committee to defer this application
so that full and proper discussions can
take
place thank you uh I I know there's
there's been some discussion on uh the
statford neighborhood plan and
uh comments were made that it's more up
to dat and it should
therefore Trump so to speak the core
strategy and I think we as a council
agree with that it's the it's the the
more upto-date evidence base and it's
part of it's part of the the the
policies we have to adhere to so I hope
that this Council will will make that
clear through someone maybe better place
to do so than myself but certainly in my
opinion the the neighborhood plan
because it is more um up toate does does
should figure you know more accurately
and more largely in in decision making
processes uh so that's just a comment
I'm sorry it's not a question um but
back to that you talked about the
housing mix and and and I know that
that's a big issue tonight um and we've
sort of been led to believe that it's it
we can't make a decision on it or we
shouldn't make a decision on it because
of these these um decisions from
planning inspectors not just in this
Council but we've looked at other places
in the country and similar decisions
have been made which is which is you
know the advice we're getting is that
you know that we would lose at appeal if
we used if we used that as an excuse um
have you got anything to say about that
anything that might help us
it just seems to me that as outline
planning permission was given some three
years
ago and at that time it was assumed that
um housing mix figures would be decided
at the uh referred matter stage that
that was quite clear at the time that
those housing mix numbers would be
defined later in the process yeah so
sure but I I I think we all agree with
that and and this has all coming as a
shock to us but it's a shock that seems
to stand in appeal decision so is there
anything you can help us get over that I
mean I I I I have talked to our planning
uh consultant at the Town Council and he
has another view on that that they that
they can be challenged so I mean I'm not
a lawyer no that's great I have to sit
here and say that's a nice piece of
information the advice that I'm being
given is that it's not necessarily set
in stone that this is an opinion by um
uh an appeals inspector and it's not yet
in any sort of legislation or or it's
thank you thank you councilor
VRI Ju Just so I'm clear so we're saying
there's there's no housing mix data now
are you actually putting forward what
what you as is it the Town Council or
whoever representing actually think the
housing mix should be are you saying it
should be the default to what is the
starting position with all housing
applications over 10 I I understand that
in any uh planning uh planning decision
there's always a discussion and there's
always compromise in it the NDP says
that they would they they want according
to the housing uh consultation that took
place that the town really needs 10% one
bed and 15% four bed the course strategy
says 5 to 10 one bed and 15 to 20% four
bed what is being uh suggested for this
application is at the upper end of that
uh is is is um 10% one bed and
20% four bed for this application so
they're going at the upper end it just
seems to me that as the co the the
neighborhood plan has different numbers
there is room there for discussion to
come up with a figure that would
actually reflect the desire of the Town
it might not be uh specific to I mean
you know there is room for discussion I
would
say I acknowled that but it seems to me
you're saying there are actually they
may be at the upper end of a range yeah
but they're within the range that that
doesn't seem to be the sort of the worst
place for them to be I'm surprised you
they're in the range
yeah
what is being um suggested by the
district is at the upper end of the
housing mix range the NDP actually has
specifics of 10% one bed and 15% uh for
bed so it's much lower because we're
looking to get a mix of houses for local
people for downsizing for uh young
people to be able to get onto the
housing ladder so you're looking for a
mix that comes down a little from the
more expensive for five bedroom houses
and that was one of the thrusts of the
neighborhood plan to try and Achieve
that going
forward great I think we can we can
cover that in in technical matters just
later on thank you uh councelor
Barnes you haven't got your neighbor had
plan yet but you're close is that or was
there a vote the other week or it went
to referendum last week and achieved um
a considerable support sort of could be
used as a factor
yeah that said an plan doesn't have to
wait to be made by the council it has
forit as soon
as okay I'll ask the aliness okay if you
want to we've got some clarification on
there just to clarify members can turn
to the update sheet it does describe how
the end having been through referendum
has full
weight okay any other questions no thank
you very much and now we're going to
have uh six minutes uh from on behalf of
the residents Association uh Kate
rol thank you before I start um I've got
figures in my latest speech as w member
about two and three bedroom housing mix
which is equally important okay I'm
speaking on behalf of the residents I'm
part of the residence working group that
has been working with the developers and
the Planner on page 17 of your report in
the third paragraph there is a note from
the inspector about the extent of The
Pedestrian and psycho links means that
the scheme could produce a high quality
and well-connected
Community we would ask the question what
cycle links I'm going to leave that one
there because I'm dumfounded that across
this entire development and I mean both
sides there's no reference to cycling at
all designing out crime policy be5 in
the neighborhood development plan please
take note of what the police have to say
and in particular the reference to the
buffer zones of 10 m at the back of
people's Gardens there is an increased
potential for burglary and the police
recommend trellis on top of 1.8 m
fencing can this be put in place we are
not clear where perimeter fencing is and
how can public access to the buffer
zones be prevented especially to the
rear of wooden close where there is a
public right of way a clear and detailed
condition needs to be put around this
issue we also have concerns about ends
of foot paaths in public open space
areas fencing and bards need to be put
in place to prevent scooters and
motorbikes accessing these areas and
causing antisocial Behavior details
around this issue needs to be
clarified the buffer zones are exactly
what it says on the tin a 10 m buffer
zone and you will see that on the
Spitfire site the buffer zones have been
encroached on there is an area where a
car park has eased into itself into the
buffer zone and mostly around the
development the foot paths are on the
buffer buff Zone
itself it will be too late to amend if
we look at the Spitfire site separately
we need to be absolutely sure that all
buffer zones are protected and not built
on including foot paaths are there
properly positioned bin stores on the
development should this be seen as
conditioned including waste
bins meter boxes on houses need to be
conditioned so that they match the color
of the elevation they are attached
to we will go into much more detail
later in my spe's W member about design
but we are generally very disappointed
with the overall design and would have
liked to have seen more distinctiveness
and sense of place to this
development we have concerns regarding
the points the planner makes in the
second paragraph on page 20 comparing
this to Bridgetown estate about 2 miles
away if she is comparing this to Trinity
made as she refers to the modern
Bridgetown then I'm slightly confused as
this estate although now well
established still has enormous problems
regarding density and congestion and the
design because it was built by different
developers it's a complete mishmash of
architecture and style and the
development has no Center or sense of
community or place people didn't
consider that important 15 16 years ago
sadly but this should be a consideration
now how will the buffer zone be
projected across the whole site we need
to have agreed all planting beforehand I
will mention in my ward counselor speech
later why I think this application
should be deferred but I have hopefully
given you some reasons so
far thank
you thank you councilor
B okay I may ask it later in technical
questions for the officers but a lot of
the points you made there it seems to be
that if they were conditioned that would
it felt like they would get over your
concerns so have you had detailed
discussions with the officers about
whether those conditions would be
acceptable I have sent the sorry I have
sent the um um Victoria and the chair of
planning a list of conditions um and um
in my opinion and the opinion of the
residents group they need to be put in
place to protect particularly all those
open place areas if you look at the top
you the huge area at the top what is
there to prevent anybody coming on and
boy racing now you more than anyone
knows Council of Audrey about what could
happen in those in those large areas my
other concern is the buffer zones uh the
inspector insisted on a 10 meter buffer
zone around the entire site um this
buffer zone has been encroached on I
believe from an earlier discussion with
Victoria that the car park has been
moved but the park Pathways haven't um
can you build pathways on the buffer
zone I don't think so the buffer zone
was put there for a specific reason it
needs to be protected it needs to
protect the residents that live on this
development and it needs to be protected
from unruly
unscrupulous antisocial Behavior thank
you um yes Kate thank you for your your
detailed uh pre- comments so to speak
which were very much noted uh discussed
and I think largely agreed with um so I
think we we've gone through meter boxes
uh the buffer
zones uh are you envisaging these buffer
zones obviously not having the footpath
through them are you envisaging them
being kind of fenced in to protect them
or just somehow protected well they need
protecting by being fenced in I mean the
police very clearly have real concerns
particularly those um those houses um
that back onto the Loxley Road the
gardens back onto the Loxley road if
they're not protected I mean you know it
just increases crime we can go through
that on technical measures needs to be
very detailed scooters and Bard and
you're talking about the northern
portion here I'm talking about all
accesses yeah to to the development
because there's a pathway that goes down
tonight's Lane um and you know if if uh
boy races want to get on there they can
unless you put ballards in place I've
had to have this done on Trinity me I've
had to have it done on other
developments in my ward okay noted and
cycle links we're all very are P Cycle
links I mean please tell me yeah I mean
the inspector says very clearly that um
the extent of The Pedestrian of cych
links means that the scheme could
produce a high quality and
well-connected Community where the cycle
links we should go cycle provision there
is none and there should be any other
questions cancer
jars sorry I'm just I'm just trying to
get to the bottom of what you're saying
about
um is it are you suggesting that there
needs to be at the beginning of the
buffer zone there needs to be fencing to
stop to stop antisocial Behavior
occurring within the buffer zone can I
just ask is not one disadvantage to that
is the purpose of zone is partly to try
to create a you know a more a more
diffuse sort of integration between the
housing and as soon as you put the fence
there that is non- green infrastructure
which is potentially um has an impact on
on on the look and the feel of it so on
balance would you not say it might it
actually be better not to have the
fencing there from from you know in
there anyway but it's the trellis that
the police have advised is put
particularly at the back of people's
Gardens right
okay okay well thank you Kate thank you
and we will now hear up to 12
minutes from Allison
Clara is that right planning agent for
the
applicant thank you chair yes my name is
Alison clar I'm a director of Serge
planning representing T wimpy um I've
been involved in a number of um
residential Reserve matter schemes in
Stratford over the last few years as
have has uh Rachel Jones who's also with
me this evening from T wimpy so to be
able to assist members with any
clarifications um in respective design
should that be necessary um just so that
you're aware of that um as officers have
indicated in the presentation to you the
matters before you for decision this
evening relate only to appearance layout
scale and
Landscaping whilst T wiy acknowledged
that there have been a number of
comments um and and concerns about a
wide range of other matters including a
number that have been raised already um
and including construction routing
traffic the location of affordable
housing units density traffic generation
it in itself um as Victor has explained
these were discussed and dealt with
either by way of safeguarding condition
or through the Section 106 requirement
by the inspector at the outline planning
stage so the starting point for the
evolution of the proposals outlined in
the report is the indicative master plan
the zoning and Landscape plan the
approved site access and the highway
upgrading
works the outline conditions also
prescribe the maximum Ridge Heights
across the site and the need for various
management details for the open space
for ecological works and Landscaping
including protected species mitigation
measures
discussion discussions regarding all of
the other matters that have been raised
where they're still ongoing um tell you
when be committed to maintaining a
dialogue with both officers and the
working group until the devel
development is delivered in full and
I'll go on to just clarify a couple of
points um
so our approach from public consultation
and engagement activity at the outset
throughout participation in the meetings
with the luxley road working group and
undertaking regular meetings with the
case officer tell you if you have sought
to listen to and respond wherever able
to the comments made in order to prepare
the best possible layout within the
parameters previously set for the
development your officers have taken us
to task on the quality of the proposal
and the need for us to pay special
attention to design detail and
Landscaping and during the course of the
application numerous design and layout
Amendments have been made some of which
are noted on the update sheet before you
but they include an increased level of
Frontage parking and dedicated visitor
parking spaces to minimize the potential
for any um inconsiderate or inconvenient
on street parking additional TR shrub
planting within the site to highlight
the designed Road hierarchy and Define
the character areas and soften the
appearance of Courtyard parking uh the
adaptation of the standard house types
to respect and reflect the local context
which feature Bays canopies Chimes and
utilize a simple but good quality pet of
materials which include brick and render
uh gray roof tiles and a varied roof PR
profile U we've included boundary walls
on key public boundaries within the
layout and the reworking of the public
private intersection within the site to
afford maximum safety to Road and
footway users alike um there is a
substantial land skape buffer um which
creates this sense of enclosure and
visual backdrop to the layout which um
we've inherited from The outl Proposal
and I completely accept the point that
there needs to be appropriate boundary
treatment to prevent an authorized
access to those elements of the
landscape buffer um that are um for buff
for literally a visual buffer only part
of the landscape buffer is actually um
area where there's a public foot path
through it so it has two different
purposes areas where it is only for um
purposes of being a a a visual and
planted buffer access will be only for
maintenance and I'm absolutely sure that
Telly M would be happy to agree an
appropriate boundary treatment with
trellising to be able to ensure that the
any potential for criminal activity is
also
minimized
um similarly no objection to conditions
relating to meter boxes in terms of the
design and appearance of the scheme um
and just picking up the point regarding
the um well connected cycle routes if
you like um there's a an acknowledgement
locally that we picked up through the
consultation that the the adjoining
roads um aren't um particularly um
inviting for people to walk along or for
people to cycle along because they don't
have a dedicated foot path so the the
connectivity is through the site on the
roads and the foot paths that are
provided within the site and there is
footpath links through and around the
open space which generally accept will
be used by younger people and
particularly linking to the school to
enable children to get to school by
cycle or scooter um but there isn't um a
requirement um for a dedicated cycle
route but rather than cycling is is is
can can occur through the site linking
it to uh amenities in The Wider area
which we've we've been able to achieve
achieve uh members have also been
advised that since the preparation of
the agenda the neighborhood PL been
through referendum we've just discussed
and Arden Heath Farm is included in the
plan as a commitment with outline
permission and the town council's raised
the issue of housing mix and hopefully
officers will be able to confirm that um
housing mix can't now be dealt with at
at this stage it it's not um a reserved
matter it's not a matter that was
reserved for consideration um and unless
a condition was attached at the outline
stage um you know unfortunately the the
housing mix issue is not something that
um that can be debated at at this stage
but not withstanding that during the
course of the preparation of the
application we've given full
consideration to the neighborhood PL
objective regarding securing high
quality places um creating distinct
character areas with logical
permeability public areas overlooked um
by a proper renting on to private drives
we've established a working group as as
as Council RF has indicated um
comprising of local stakeholders um
which we've been able to develop the
proposal and discuss the the various
elements of character within the street
scene um there's a strong green
infrastructure um to ensure the as
required by The Neighborhood plan that
the new homes respect the site's
relationship with um both the
countryside and its position on um
within
Stratford um
as a result that there's no conflict
with the the the spirit and purpose of
of the um of the neighborhood plan
itself so I think in in in summary
there's there's recognition that there
are enormous difficulties uh working in
a collaborative manner on a project that
both the council itself and local
residents sought to to resist but where
details haven't been bound by the
outline permission t t p s very uh hard
to create a scheme that ensures the
continuity of the key design features
and establishes the identity and sense
of place befitting of its location
within
Stratford so as as required by the
policies of the of the wider development
plan for Stratford the reserve matters
reflect an embody local character given
the prescribed scale and density um it
creates a high uh creates a high quality
layer utilizing materials design and
Landscaping
proposals excuse me which provides a
development that tay won't be proud of
and where people will want to live um so
uh members are respectfully requested to
follow the recommendation officers have
provided thank you thank you
uh oh you think councelor VRI first
okayl of you um so obviously we'll ask
officers in technical questions later on
about housing mix but given that you've
you've been aware what that was in the
local plan I've got four questions I'll
bundled together if I may um you aware
what was in the local plan um do you
have any objection to the numbers that
are in the local plan as a as a as a
base for for where you as a developer
should be second question was I'm not
convinced you really address the whole
cycling point I'm afraid I'm a I'm a
cycle fan and if you haven't got cycle
Lanes in there I know what it's like to
be on paths when you got kids crossing
you or roads where you you can get hit
by cars I think that is a major failing
if you haven't as a proactive green
developer all that nonsense that you
haven't got any cycle Lanes I would I I
would really struggle to vote in support
of this motion if if you don't sort that
out thirdly on the lack of Distinction
that councilor wolf talked about on the
design what have you specifically said
to the residents groups about their
feedback on the design it it didn't look
great but I I I also accept that's a
subjective comment but what are you
doing to make sure this is is a design
that is better than other developments
that you said you've worked on in the
town and just lastly on you said you
accept some conditions you you outlin
them I suppose I'm more interested in
the ones that councilor wol and Council
fagy have flagged that you would be
reluctant to accept so for instance
issues on the buffer zone are you happy
to accept all the major points that both
councilors have have flagged this
afternoon yeah I mean I think yeah um in
terms of conditions there's nothing
that's been addressed that we don't we
certainly don't want a scheme where
there's um antisocial Behavior where
there's any fear of crime so any any of
the police comments that we can take on
board the conditions that have been
suggested on um buffer boundary
treatment absolutely happy to accept um
in terms of the um the the cycling Lanes
there's no requirement for the to be
cycling Lanes just only that the site is
well connected so we're not uh we're not
required to provide cycling lanes and
it's not it's an edge of uh rural Edge
we wouldn't we think it would be over
engineered to have cycle pass through
the site but you can cycle on the roads
through the site and also we wouldn't
want to encourage um cycl cyclists to
come out onto any of the Junctions we
talked with the working group about
having foot path links and cycle links
that came out onto um luxley Road and
kns Lane and they said no because the
it's not good for crossing you need to
be able to come in and out of the main
axis so you've got good visibility so we
have rehearsed some of the other links
that you could have in and around the
site but the fact that the the foot path
links go through from the existing
residential dwellings through the site
up to the school where a new foot paath
is being created in any event um you can
go out of the site and up to the school
is probably going to be the main users
of the
site um we we are aware of the numbers
that are in the neighborhood plan but
again we've not we've not um had to have
regard to that that because the housing
mix is in has being accepted by the
local Authority so we we've we haven't
had to have regard to
that okay councel Roberts Richards who's
C
Roberts um so I've got two questions um
I was going to use my housing mix one as
my second one but given we're on that
topic now we'll we'll keep going with it
um the outline permission I didn't sit
on the committee at that point so I have
no idea how much debate or discussion
was had at that stage about housing mix
was there any um and as part of that uh
if there was Does this comply with what
was agreed at that stage I'm not
convinced there was I think there was a
layout and that was it um does this
comply with what they think there was
and on what basis have you guys come to
the decision that you should be on the
higher end of the one and the four beds
as has been indicated by uh both
councelor fragile and councelor rol um
and and was there any movement in that
during the process and I'll ask the
second one once you've responded to that
okay um I wasn't um involved in the um
outline either so I I've only been able
to go through the um the supporting
information in the inspector's decision
and I'm not aware of there being any um
dialogue or prescription but it was at
that time that had the inspector wanted
to prescribe a housing mix or tie the
housing mix to any policy that that
would have been the time that it would
have been done and in the absence of
that it is it is with agreement with the
local Authority that the housing mix is
appropriate and um and and that so that
that's the route we've
taken thank you um and the second
question is about the design um having
looked at the examples of the design
there I can't pretend that I'm overly
thrilled or excited by them um clearly
you are one of three phases built form
phases um it appears to me that the
submitted for phase two two and three or
I think or was it three and four and
five or
something yeah differ significantly from
what you're producing um this is for a
wider this is part of a whole scheme in
order to create some form of community
some sort of consistency through there
presumably you've had dialogue with uh
the promoters of the other two
phases is that right what what dialogue
have you had and why do your properties
differ so significantly from what
they're bringing forward okay there's
been um the working group has been made
up of a a member of Spitfire and Taylor
there's a collab agreement between the
two uh developers and there's a large
number of of houses being proposed on
The Wider site um TM have a more
traditional approach to the development
and spitfire have a um a more
contemporary approach so it provides the
the biggest variety of housing types and
styles to to to the offer within
statford they differ probably more away
from the Loxley road but we've worked
very closely with um Spitfire to make
sure that the the street frontages um
are um um consistent in terms of
replicating the rest of luxley Road in
terms of variety um um Ridge Heights
materials um larger units so we've
worked together on the on the main
frontages but the remainder of the site
yet that they they offered us different
the the hat is different the house types
do
differ okay councelor Barnes
um I wondered if we could have a picture
of the W bedroom or what we call two
bedroom has it so I can ask the question
on
design and
then yeah
yes well that one was all right yes so
that is is that the one bedroom or the
two bedroom or is that the one the two
bedrooms three bedroom three bedroom
that one that's a three bedom have we
got a one
bedroom you haven't got one oh okay well
I can't have about design
then okay councel
Oran thank you chairman um about
connectivity can you tell me is there a
foot paast link between the new access
into the development and the existing
foot paath in Loxley road so that say
anyone who lived there who wanted to
walk to the bus stop could do
so and or into Stratford and the
footpath link through into um Morton
close no it's not Morton close
close thank you can you tell me how wide
that
is I'll try the the footpath if you come
out of them the the main entrance of the
site and turn left there is that will be
a foot paath um that we'll be able to
use and there's a crossing point to a
footpath the other side of the road so
so along um along luxley Road there will
be uh Road improvements with a central
reservation so that you can stop and
cross um so in terms of the foot links
in and in and out of the site will be
dedicated new foot paaths
provided the foot path link from the
through to wooden close I don't know how
wide it is I know that we've had a lot
of representation saying it's two foot
two foot um we've had representation
States it's not um a particularly wide
footpath it's outside of the site and
it's not within any requirement for a t
to look at it however we have through
the working group said that during the
course of the construction that they
would be able to um surface it and widen
it and CLE clean it up and tidy it up to
the best of their ability whilst they're
on
site okay sorry can we uh just keep it
to the committee thank you Council
Oregan how do you widen it sorry not
only in as much that it's it's cleared
of of of um vegetation yeah it it can't
be widened
yeah councelor
Charles I just wondered if you could
explain to me how um because I can't
quite understand how the connectivity
Works in ter terms of uh people on the
these two phases accessing play space
and so I mean am I right in
understanding that the piece at the top
is supposed to be public open space
that's available for the site it is yes
so are you able to just explain to me
what the connectivity is for these
phases of the site and how anyone either
walking there or cycling there would
want to get her to that top part we have
got a connectivity plan I don't know
whether you might have it there Victoria
now um there are there is there's two
two two areas o space there's the area
at the north of the site uh which has
got the a play area but there's also a
second area at the bottom which is a
linear area of o space so that would
also be within very comfortable walking
distance but because we haven't got a
Spitfire layout showing all the roads
and the footways you would be able to
cross over the road using the central
Refuge onto the footpath through the
site and then there's a there's um a a a
footpath route all around the top of the
site if you like to so that you could do
a circular walk and come back if you
wanted to go for a walk or whatever but
you would go through the site through
the roads so that people could see what
was going on in the activity we we not
inclined to get um foot path links round
through the buffer zones for the reasons
we've mentioned but also Around The
Wider site we don't want people to be
out on crossing the main road other than
going through the onto the proper
crossing point on Loxy
Road councilor
VRI um I
declare the interest I used to be a
governor of the C school but I no longer
am but what provision if someone lives
on that site and they have kids who are
going to the Croft is there any
provision to make that Journey
safe in what respect sorry once they
leave the
site no more than anybody else who lives
on Loxley Road it would you mean by fot
Council
V by foot or by bike I'm just curious I
suppose whether there's any conditioning
that's been appli
to make sure that there is safe passage
for young children to get to that school
without having to use a
car only through the the routes that
have been made available through the
site I think we can go to technical on
that yeah yeah sorry yeah uh any other
questions thank you very much you thank
you and we will hear now again from
councelor Ral I think as Ward member
who's got 10
minutes and may well use them all yeah
there's two
applications
oh I shall wait I think yeah if you work
don't mind
waiting
spe
minutes I said it might be two days
things so that was uh some prepar Reed
was the coun so apologies Mr chairman
you know thank you um before I start I
just want to clarify this footpath going
down to Wood and close um it's a very
narrow TW foot footpath that exists
there are properties either side uh it
is not maintained um I think we'll have
to include this in your in your 10
minutes if anyway um I set up a working
group of residents to work with myself
the developers and with the planner
Taylor Wimpy have taken on board some of
of our concerns for instance visitor
parking but not all as they have not
addressed our concerns of our overall
design at our last meeting over 3 weeks
ago when we had ready an updated list of
design concerns the planner openly
announced when asked that she would be
putting this application forward for
approval and that she didn't have an
issue with the
design we as a group were pretty taken
back by this open admission so far in
advance of this committee date and
before the planner at home heard what we
had to say this left us without any
negotiating power we felt that there was
no point in pursuing any design details
when I did mention quality of design
Taylor wimpy were quite
offended our first main concern is that
of poor design and poor quality which
does not Accord with policy cs9 of the
core strategy and be1 of the
neighborhood development plan you will
have all received a pretty detailed list
of design issues which I sent you which
we believe should be addressed before
any pro approval is given this is
standard wimpy patent book development
with houses you will find anywhere in
this country no distinctiveness and no
character please refer to the detailed
list I sent you in advance generally the
elevations submitted neither take the
opportunity to create a new development
with a clear and distinctive character
of its own or create a development which
reflects any of the locally and
distinctive character of the buildings
around this development this development
is no more than a mish mash of
lowquality standard house Builder
elevations that don't relate to each
other or the local area and do not
create a sense of space The New National
policy planning framework that was
adopted in the summer is National
guidance and one of its key aims is to
drive up the quality of development
which importantly is based upon good
Design This has not being picked up by
the planning officer at all in her
report in the mppf 56 it states attaches
great importance to the design of the
built environment and in N pf61 it
states it recognizes that security
securing high quality and inclusive
design goes beyond aesthetic
considerations and expects planning
decisions to address the connections
between people and places and the
integration of new developments into the
Natural Built and historic
environment there have been a number of
recent appeal decisions that have
refused permission from the planning
inspectorate that included poor quality
design in their reasons for refusing
permission SDC have adopted design
guidance within their adopted core
strategy therefore that is a material
consideration when determining
applications the committee report says
these are out of date and should not be
used this is not correct in the adopted
NE neighborhood development plan
policies be1 and be6 states that all
developments must demonstrate a high
standard of design and layout through
the following ways permeability variety
and legibility I believe there is
further we work which needs to be taken
on by Taylor wimpy to achieve the above
which is why I'm asking you to defer
this application this will give Taylor
wimpy and the working group and I would
suggest including someone from the Town
Council planning committee an
opportunity to look at design again and
hopefully this application can come to
committee at the same time as the
Spitfire application who will be
developing the other side of the Loxy
Road it will give you a chance to look
at the scheme as a whole this will also
ensure that you'll be able to look at
both sides of the frontage of the
Locking Road in terms of Street Scene
which is very
important density we have a huge
concerns regarding the density of this
application this reaches 38.5 per
hectare I think you will find that it
becomes even more dense at the back of
the site where properties are packed
very tightly together by removing a few
properties in this section and placing
at the other end towards the front of
the Loxy Road it'll ease the density
considerably actually in the appeal
document the inspector States up to 270
houses so theoretically there could be
less properties across both
sites in the NDP policy H7 it states
very clearly that all developments on
the edge of town should be at a density
of 25 or thereabouts and the properties
should filter in as you approach the
development I have concerns that a
significant amount of housing will be on
a rising Hill and will appear dense and
congested in policy B six of the nebal
development plan it states that in large
developments there should be 10% of
Bungalows provided for the less Wella
members of our community there are four
Bungalows provided in this application
and not one of them on the Spitfire
development there is another reason to
look at the two together so that some
cohesion between the two developers
allows for more
Bungalows I'm going to talk to you about
housing mix I know we've discussed it
before but I'm more concerned about the
two and three bedroom rooms in the
rental and shared ownership side SDC
policy 80% rented and 20% shared we have
here 35 rented and it should be 37 and
12 shared ownership and it should be
nine Taylor wimp here providing 48% and
SDC policy is 35 to 40% for two bedrooms
I.E they are providing 23 times two
bedrooms and it should be providing 18
Taylor wimia providing 32% three
bedrooms and SDC policy is 35 35 to 40%
in other words they are over providing
two beds and under providing three beds
one of four beds are only mentioned in
the report in the private mix Taylor
wimp are providing 4.5% of one beds SDC
policy of 15 to 20% Taylor wimpier under
providing two bedrooms against minimum
of 30 to 40% four bedrooms are at the
upper limit this housing M needs to be
sorted out before this application is is
approved a comprehensive list of
conditions I sent the list to Victoria
and to Justin and I would add to that
the list there should be a protection
around the public open space to prevent
unwanted and antisocial behavior and
finally
highways I know a lot of background work
has taken place between the developers
and Ben Sim and it has been discussed at
length at our meetings and sadly there's
no easy solution however I would want to
see the tracking approved by the highway
Authority before agreeing to rep approve
this application if anything changes I.E
the tracking shows there could be a
problem then it will be too late to
amend the layout to accommodate highway
safety by deferring it it will give
everyone time to achieve the best
possible safety for all of our
residents so in summary I would ask that
this application is deferred to allow
for any alterations to design and
housing mix that this committee deems
necessary and for the working group to
work together with the developers to
achieve all the points mentioned above I
would also like this committee to ask
that Spitfire the developers of the
other half of the site comes to this
committee at the same time as Taylor
wimpy amended scheme so that you all get
a chance to see the overall scheme in
its
entirety I now I I've got a bit of time
I sent you all um um 15 points of design
issues that I have I'm happy to read
them out again but you have all been
sent them would you like me to read them
out okay plots 80 to 91 need to be
symmetrical on approaching Street to act
as a focal point and terminate Vista
exposed rear fence to plot 115 is not
good termination a Vista dominance of
Frontage parking EG plots 21 to 28
Corner turkey turning dual elevated
house taxes need needed on Corner plots
EG plots 55 51 and 17 some houses have
only one parking space some house types
drawn with larger studies instead of
bedrooms Dodge the mix policy type aa11
drawn as one-bedroom house with study
but clearly is a two-bedroom house type
poly position plots on bz I plots 208
111 and 112 exposes lots of blank Gable
to Street Scene lots of very narrow
detached house types not typical of the
area and creates poor Street Scene
generally the house types are a mismash
of different design styles with no
particular reference to the context
subsequently the design has no coherent
identity locally hipped roofs and bay
windows are prevalent the proposed
elevations miss these details almost
completely roof pitches on T types are
very shallow and not typical of the con
contextual roof space porches on some
types are very small and look poor large
format contract roof concrete roof tiles
proposed not typical of the area and
give low quality appearance window
detailing all house types lack seal
detailing some heads use vire brick
arches with stone keystones this is not
typical of the area all of the houses
are tailor wimpy houses you see all over
across this country there is no
distinctiveness I think is all very
important to hopefully achieving a
better quality development this
velopment will be with us forever and we
should ensure that it's the best poity
possible quality design development it
can be I we are willing as a working
group to work further with um Taylor
wimpy um and the agent and we want a
good quality designed development thank
you that's really very good 3 seconds to
go thank you councelor Sor I didn't
mention conditions but I I'm happy to go
through with condition okay uh any
questions councelor Richard just a quick
one so um that list you gave us at the
end thank you for that I haven't got the
email with me but I did receive it um
they appear predominantly to be
aesthetic issues um one of the things
you said about good design and the the
new mppf coming in is that good design
goes beyond Aesthetics is there anything
else over and above what you've listed
that you think is important for us to
consider in terms of the design and out
of this place
yes I think some variation in rendering
some variation in Ridge Heights some
variation in window details um some
better quality porches some better
quality layouts and some better better
quality designs we don't want tailor
wimpy houses that we see everywhere else
simple as
that uh councelor
barns I was going to ask about parking
you said some houses only had one one
place some place some has got open
parking we were sort of against that as
well what is your feeling of the site on
parking well they they have um after
working with us they have put in um um
some visitor parking in my opinion not
enough they've got no visitor parking on
that bit of the development um sorry
that bit of the
development but there are there are
houses with one parking space
and there's too many tandem parking
spaces in my opinion but I know
that other people differ in their
opinion on tandem parking Council
VRI Council I think I'm just trying to
get the bottom of what what you want in
your ideal world because obviously we'll
leave it to officers for me to ask the
question about housing mix and what this
committee can and cannot do so setting
Council frag Point aside it would appear
that the developers willing to pretty
much accept the conditions that you're
putting forward so on that
basis and about cycling names why why do
you want you then were implying about
trying to defer this so it comes in
tandem with Spitfire but but is that a
reasonable request in or can you justify
why that would be a reasonable request
if if they're accepting all the other
conditions okay because um it was
mentioned earlier um about um the
difference in Des design and difference
in detail between Taylor wimpy and
spitfire it's always been an issue from
the working group's point of view that
um the Spitfire
Frontage compared to the Taylor wimpy
Frontage on the Loxy road is going to be
so different I mean so different that it
will look completely odd and out of
character with the Loxy road now one
could argue that the Spitfire lines up
with the left hand side of already on
the Loxy Road and the right hand side
but I I want to see something
that that
creates an overall development of very
good quality and what you will get with
Spitfire is the good quality and what
you get with Taylor wimia is not so good
quality and it will be a marked
difference I'm I'm about quality and
about design um and I think I think I
slightly disagree that what you said
about it's all aesthetic I think there's
um there are houses with open Gables
that are hitting you there's no sense of
place in this development um I remember
going to a training session about design
and sense of place there is no sense of
place they are going to be very very
different anyway but there's no sense of
place it's very dense look at the bottom
at how dense it is it's cramped it's
dense there's no feeling of
community and I'm about good quality
design that creates a sense of place and
I think Taylor wimpy could do better
they did better a few years ago and
councelor Oram will know this when they
worked with this on poppy Meadow after
they got a refused application I'm not
asking for this to be refused I'm asking
for Taylor wimpy to come up to the mark
and design something a little bit better
and they can do that thank you sorry off
my high horse uh can you go through um
one or two of those things exactly and
can the officer please point out where
we're talking about your exposed
A-frames and and Gables just one or two
of those on the plan if the officer
has so got plots if you go from the top
you got plots 80 to 91 uh need to be
symmetrical I think that's actually been
altered yeah are we happy with with
that please do so I looked at the pl on
on seeing that and um I I'm assuming
that we're talking about this
terminating Vista here and it's 80 and
81 are adjacent to each other
so comment unless I see close numbers so
so 80 and 81 are join each other so in
terms of a terminating Vista I assumed
it was a typo because 91's all the way
around the corner um so I'm assuming
that's what we're looking at in that
comment and um whe so this is one of a
pair and it it's at the head of this
road here um and it will have a
symmetrical property attached to it um
viewed from this
road soorry you're waiting for me to
talk yes so so has that been changed or
is that what we're we're looking at that
that was what that's what was proposed
yes that's what that's and what is
proposed that's what's currently being
proposed and we have an argument with
that because it's not it's not a
landmark it's not a focal point is that
right
yeah are you saying it should be a
bigger house with more character
something like that there should be a
sense of you know identity you know I
live to the left of that very large
house as you approach this lovely road I
get it I get it
okay and poorly positioned plots can you
show these we've got poorly positioned
plots on Ben's 28111 1112 exposed blank
Gables to the street point seven yes
poly bision plots on Bends um and so on
the bend you're going to see as you turn
the bend you're going to see a very
large um exposed Gable which is you know
really not very attractive on the street
scene if we can try and find one of
these examples at
least there this one on the corner
here yeah I have got it that one there
we go ugly unattractive doesn't need to
be so as as you am I okay to comment
yeah so as you turn the corner here you
would have um a view of the side of that
property so you would have a side all
right I understand okay so I just want
to draw out some of the actual specifics
Kate's talking about here so that's
we've got several instances of that
um and the porches maybe can we have a
look at some of these
porches is that one there that's a
detail of our Port there's there's
several different very small and they
look
pretty they look like well I options
okay thank I just wanted to get a feel
in pictures of what you were talking
about so I know what you're talking
about any other
questions no okay thank you very much
right thank
you uh so technical question
questions councelor
bars exactly sure in the respect it was
said that the outline was three years
ago are
we are we under pressure to make a
decision because the board member said
all of a sudden the the officer decided
to go to committee but I'm saying is if
we were to defer it or do whatever are
we in
a
still in in a legal
position you happy me to can we have a
comment on that understand yeah um so
it's a question on deferment is it yes
on so uh from the point of view the the
outline application had a condition on
it which required the date in which um
Reserve matter should be submitted that
was submitted in time so um in relation
to a determination there's no
requirement for us Det as long as they
put it Forward we're all right that said
obviously we are required to look at
things in a timely manner um performance
um agreements have been put in place to
to try to deal with that but ultimately
it is within your gift to make a
recommendation and I can understand both
side but I thought legally but legally
there there is no reason for us not to
okay before we go on uh just just to
make it clear if we did go down a
deferment route that would mean we
weren't saying yes we want to approve it
or yes we want to reject it we want to
put a pause on it for further work um
there was a question on that last time
so councelor Richards um thank you the
um first question would be to uh
approach the outline and Reserve matters
and what is and isn't being decided um
mind standing of outline particularly in
this case was it was outline um with
detail on the rad all other matters
reserved um my understanding of all
means everything other than and that
would include how include housing mix um
the indication that we've been given is
that um there have been appeal decisions
that have said we don't have to worry
about housing mix because it's not been
part of it we weren't part of that
decision- making and had we been
granting I think perhaps we probably
would have done so can you explain to me
why we're not discussing it now and once
you've done that can you explain to me
what uh external opinion on what basis
what opinion we're we're giv that on is
it your opinion is it our Council
opinion or is it external Council opin
have we sought proper Council opinion on
it yeah um so on having read um uh
appeal decisions General um knowledge of
of planning and taking that forward and
there was a recent decision that came
through to the council um we also sought
external um guidance at that point and
found out that other inspectors have
made made other similar decisions in
other local authorities in relation to
housing mix um certainly the focus that
that or the message that's come through
for the planning inspectorate is that uh
the matters that you reserve for
consideration are set at outline so um
if you decide to so access was agreed
there are four other Reserve matters so
they're clearly for consideration under
this I think there has um historically
been an assumption that things like
layout and scale scale affect mix but
inspectors have said no that is not as
defined by the general development
procedure order this is clearly what
that says and so if you wanted to fix
that as a reserve matter at outline
stage it should be conditioned as such
at the time of the outline um the core
strategy wasn't in place um the
neighborhood development wasn't in place
and I don't know because I wasn't
involved in those discussions I suspect
that the whole issue of mixed wasn't
particularly discussed at that point as
a a massive concern at that moment in
time for the council um and therefore
wasn't something that was reserved for
consideration at that point in time so
we are now in a position unfortunately
where Reserve matters have been
submitted sometime later when we do have
those policies in place and certainly if
this would come in before me right now
as a full application or an outline
application I would be insisting on the
mix that's that's agreed at um
neighborhood development you know within
within the neighborhood development plan
um the discussions with the applicant
were you were very aware that of the mix
that's being proposed they have that's
in the core strategy and I advise you to
adhere to that they've certainly look to
meet it um with regards to the core
strategy they haven't gone as far as
reaching the top the the more diff not
the more difficult but the more defined
levels are set out in the neighborhood
development plan so my comments and my
report is presented to you and as as
defining now is I don't think that mix
is a matter that we should be
considering but in any event it has been
cons considered in addition to that
affordable housing is required via the
section 106 agreement and that specifies
what should and shouldn't be provided
and is a matter of legal course so that
has to be provided and is dealt with
under that separate
matter okay so because so we didn't make
the decision to Grant the outline so we
wouldn't at that point be in a position
to give consideration to layout we
refused outright so a decision has been
made that's outside our of control we
now have to adhere to someone else's
decision have we sought legal counsil as
to whether that is appropriate or
whether we can now clearly planning
decisions are made on a case-by Case
basis we're told that repeatedly um when
it comes to planning inspector decisions
surely they're treated on a case-by
casee basis as well and given this
decision was taken outside of our hands
can we not now go back to to the
planning inspector or to coun and say
look we think we should be applying a
specific um mix to it what is their
opinion um okay we haven't in this
particular instance sought separate
legal advice on the nature of um Reserve
matters and the need to or otherwise
consider housing mix um what's been
quite plain from inspector's decisions
elsewhere and our handling of other
applications is that um where outline
permission has been granted and a
condition hasn't been imposed that says
matters relating to housing mix are
reserved then it is assumed that those
matters have not been reserved if you
like I think our advice to members
should be clear it's that inspectors are
likely to take the view that housing mix
is not a matter that has been reserved
in this instance and therefore it is you
know deemed to be agreed effectively and
is not a matter for consideration as
part of these applications can we can we
have Ross comment
or we we did obtain external legal
advice on this um when we got the appeal
decision um that said we couldn't
consider mix as a reserve matter we
wanted to challenge that and we we
sought we sought advice from leading
count s who advised that yeah that
that's the the correct interpretation um
you can only consider Reserve matters
you know access landscape scale layout
they are defined in legislation as
Reserve matters isn't a reserve matter
if you want to control it it has to have
been made a condition pursuant to the
outline right okay okay I've got more
but I need to digest that from canc
or thank you chairman yeah I'm looking
for clarity about density um because I
fully understand that the inspector has
set a maximum figure of houses on this
site and he has defined where those
houses can go but there is also the
question of the policy for
25% on out of town um Edge of Town
development so I'm just looking for some
clarity on this because the two are not
similar I I've assessed this application
and given you my judgment based on the
conditions that were imposed at outline
stage and which dictated the a level of
and Quantum of development that could be
achieved on this site so um because
housing is restricted to these specific
zones uh and a Quantum of up to 270 was
accepted by the inspector and in his
report he noted that whilst it would be
higher um density
than in those areas because of the
amount of open space that surrounded it
he he felt that that would be acceptable
so I've taken that as my steer uh in
making a judgment yes there is a
disparity um with with the neighborhood
development plan plan that's come
forward but I think I in giving you a
judgment I have to be informed by the
information that's before me and what
has been agreed and from my perspective
I felt that the density was acknowledged
and agreed by the inspector at that
moment in time um and and that's really
what should give us the the biggest
steerers to the Quantum of development
that could be achieved on site and
therefore the densities in those areas
by pure nature that you have to go into
certain pockets of the site so you can't
increase the density
you know across the entirety of the site
and have a more spacious development by
encroaching into the open space areas
and the green buffer
areas okay councelor
VRI two points are there any of
councilor rol's conditions that you
think are not appropriate from a
planning point of view and
secondly uh the point she made about the
the two different developers and how
they're
that you know they all look in Congress
against each
other I strongly think we can do
anything about that when I would be are
we able to somehow condition that there
should be some similarity of design
between different developers or is that
beyond our
scope just so we know if there is
anything we can do about it or
not I think essentially it won't be
necessary um we have just recently
received the planning application for
Reserve matters um to the north of the
site the Spitfire side if you like um
it's currently out to consultation we're
not yet at a stage where we know what
feedback we will receive in that there's
considerable scope to look at that in
terms of appearance and ensure that it's
um something that is cohesive um with
this application if it is one which
members resolve to
approve
no I think I think they they are
acceptable I would note that there is an
enclosures plan that's been submitted
with the original application um with
with
the with the housing application so that
details that that that the you can't get
onto the buffer zone certainly on the
southern part of the site um I think it
would however be reasonable um in
thinking about boundary treatment or
bards or something certainly leading on
to the open space areas and that hasn't
been covered by the enclosures plan but
the other the other conditions I think
are
reasonable cancel ainson uh yes chairman
mention has been made of
Spitfire if uh this development was
let's say a bit of a
copycat do Spitfire operate in a similar
price bracket as tayor wimpy for the
sale of the
homes not sure it's strictly a planning
matter but my understanding is that they
don't uh councelor
Giles do you have any pictures of the
pro I'm thinking about the Loxley Road
strip and going back to Council of ud's
point in this cohesion do we have any um
uh indication of the Spitfire plans are
we able to compare oh that's it I wonder
if I could just have um focusing in on
the different things because it's just a
bit
distant
come I'll got
[Applause]
some Pro so these properties in the
middle here um proposed are the spit
Spitfire properties I believe
um and then there are the Taylor wimpy
proposals those are the existing Loxley
Road
properties if that's any
help so that's that's sorry just and
that's the that's what Spitfire spit
ones what we understand to be the
Spitfire
properties and that's what's proposed
and that's what's proposed
adjacent as I intimated before the
Spitfire proposals are very new um have
not been through technical consideration
as of yet
um there is certainly scope with both of
these applications to um consider design
and that's existing and that's
existing sorry canc and then could I
just would you a to just slowly flick
through the designs that you have W
within the site um and actually I'm
wondering in particular whether you have
anything so you see the bend where it's
quite dense on the I suppose it's in
the sorry that's okay yes so you see the
blue housing there that's sort of quite
dents and I wonder if you've got any of
this that street view there and what
that's going to look like so that um
street view is this one here so this is
the more dense that's a a street view um
of that slightly more dense Main Street
area could I see that a bit closer sorry
my
eyes
help he and can you go down to the the
side streets as well because that's the
main drag with the trees on that's the
nice
stuff that's the street scene that looks
onto the No No Yeah I mean the the real
the ones tucked away where no one's
going to going to see street so much the
ones down the bottom close to the
boundary I don't think we have Street
scenes for those we don't individual
elev can you show us some indiv yeah do
we have that I don't think on the PL I'd
have to go into
edms unfortunately we're not part of the
presentation presentation we can get you
want to bear with us for a minute can
you do that and we ask other questions
at the yeah okay we're going to go for
that because I think it's important to
see you know those those little teres at
the bottom with loads of parking in
front of them those are the ones I think
we want to get down to um in the
meantime any other questions councelor
Oran thank you chairman um did uh
councelor R's list of
[Music]
um
items um include resurfacing the foot
the existing foot path and clearing it
and making the actual surface as wide as
it possibly was the
conditions you mean the existing uh
public footpath between the houses onto
the
close sorry just to clarify that that's
widening of the the existing footpath on
Wen close are you asking about okay
so okay so the um the outline consent um
had as part of the section 106 agreement
um a payment towards um General footpath
Improvement now that didn't specifically
say that that would be that foot path
but there was a requirement in relation
to the wider site that that that would
go forward uh the conditions haven't
asked for it and we wouldn't be able to
ask for financial contribution vir a
condition to improve the quality of that
but it is my understanding that the
developer is willing to improve that um
but it would be outside of any planning
condition or
agreement okay yeah that's a terrible
little muddy foot path I went down it
the other day and it's terribly narrow
but I guess that's to do with the the
people who are in the property either
side sorry Council
organ you question it yeah yeah I'm I'm
sure that our examples of developments
where
offsite um works that are necessary for
the development have been agreed either
in conditions or in section 106 and I'm
thinking for instance of um developments
along the banry road contributing trees
along the banry road as part of uh
that's the one that Springs to mind but
there are others and I so I'm having
some difficulty with this because this
footpath link is
sold as being crucial and all part of
the permeability and the
connectivity of the development when you
in reality you can't get a double buggy
down
it I think councelor you do make a valid
point and whilst it's not explicitly
stated in the outline planning
application nor the section 106 I think
as the County Highway officer as it's
the county council's responsibility to
look after footpaths that we can look
into that matter as part of the section
106 works and I can take that away from
this evening that the the the members of
this committee felt that that
contribution should be perhaps focused
in part to improving that foot path um
and improving up to a greater standard
from its existing um condition to a hard
surfaced uh uh uh hard
surface for use can I just add I mean
can you make it
wider it's it's it's it's within the
it's within what land is available if
there is some marginal ANS available
there is opportunity if there isn't then
there's not a lot we can do there's none
okay uh back to your pictures uh Council
GS yeah so just to confirm this is one
of the dwelling types that would um sit
within a muse of properties in the C tax
which you referred to
okay that's a that's a yeah
okay anything else on
design Council
Oran I assume that is the one bedroom
dwelling that that is up
there yes can you tell me what size the
study
is yes if you bear if you bear with
me
I'd like a study that
big approximately 9 and a half Square
met
approximately n and a half square meters
okay thank you uh right can I just go
through a few things um in green
infrastructure that's the second part of
it we're approving what's before us as
an idea um obviously the the northern
side is it all going to be built out is
it all going to be built out as we're
approving it
at the same time as this development is
built out I'm not sure why the northern
portion would be built out at the same
time but you know what's the time scale
of
buildout and what are the conditions
ensuring that whatever should be ready
for these houses is ready and whatever
should be ready presumably for the other
houses is
ready
So within um within the outline
application there is actually a
condition in relation to the timing of
um landscape details as a phasing matter
um within
the application for the housing I have
asked for the Landscaping to be provided
concurrently um in relation to sort of
trees going through streets I haven't
specifically put that condition onto the
Landscaping um application but I think
that it would be reasonable to do so so
so we're talking about the boundary
treatments okay we need it to come in
before the first occupation
obviously is that is that is that Reon
able normally what we would seek is for
landscaping buffer um to be planted in
the first planting season following
occupation okay that's normal okay fair
enough and what about the play area down
there on the south or the the
recreational
area uh ordinarily you would seek for
those features to be delivered alongside
the Housing Development so that can be
before first
occupation certainly could be made
available concurrently with those plots
for sale before those plots yeah and and
the Western plots as well all of
them it's open for members to consider
okay we can we can we can set that and
what about the northern
portion I just wondering where that
comes into things the nor the northern
portion includes within it the the
drainage um for the site so that's
another reason that it's been brought
forward um that's been submitted under
another application so there will be a
desire to provide that um early in the
scheme because it's required uh in in
terms of the overall development um I
think we could condition a future
application in relation to when that's
delivered I.E the Spitfire homes
application um as and when that's
approved as to when that's delivered but
who's build who's building it out the
this Northern portion it's a mixture of
the the two
developers so it's been
submitted so it's going to be so apology
it has been submitted it has been um
provided by uh Taylor wimpy at this
point so it will be Taylor wimpy that
would be building that
out um right I'm just going to go down
um cycle links we cycle links will have
to come into the next one
um okay we'll go on Council of
Audrey sorry I forgot last time to ask
about the cycle link so we had the
developer say they you know they weren't
going to do them uh um Council fraggy
obviously as a keen cyclist flagged it
I'm can you just clarify what can we
condition the developer to do in terms
of cycle paths so conditioning of the
outline um required a pedestrian stroke
cycle link um through the northern part
of the site from Loxley V tonight's Lane
as generally shown on the illustrative
master plan um if I go back to them so
in general accordance with this I think
it's pretty clear that this didn't show
dedicated cycle links through the
through the site in terms of width and
um in in looking at it we've looked at
connectivity so that you know there is
this existing access here that was was
considered at the indicative outline
stage we've got we've got the slow speed
Road through the s where you could cycle
or or walk and then you've got public
foot paths through the site leading all
the way through up to the top of nights
L but I think Ben can probably
clarify Ben also just say you're
clarifying is there a different spec
between building something that's
defined as pedestrian and something
that's defined as a cycle path or is
there a specific spec for something
that's deemed to be both um in terms of
specifications I'll just do with that
first a foot path or a foot footway is
generally 2 m wide a shared footway
Cycle Way is 3 m wide in this
development case the development is a
cisac development so the road hierarchy
has been designed off manual for streets
a design speed of 20 mph has been
utilized which in that case the road
should the carriageway should cater for
both cyclists and vehicles it's a
low-speed environment it's been through
a very heavy assessment by the County
Council in terms of the layout and it
will go through further assessments
through technical
approval it because it's a cyck it
doesn't meet the coun council's criteria
for what we determine as our community
spine which is what where we would have
a bus service that was coming in and
that would be a loop and on that we
would have separate provision for
footway cycleways but because this is a
cuy saac and the road width goes down to
5.5 m is actually not of a standard
where you'd have Standalone cycle
features provided they can be
accommodated within the carriageway in
terms of offsite provision that was was
considered and ter of the out outline
planning application but from all the
documentation I've seen there's no
contribution to cycling improvements
outside of the site and there's no
condition by the one that um Victoria
has mentioned tonight regarding any
other cycle Improvement so we can only
consider actually what's what's in front
of us on that on that point okay CCH us
of the time here uh councelor
Giles no councelor
V got to stop mixing the Serv
up canc I'm considerably younger
and um tell you back to that one bedroom
place um it clearly has a 9.5 is meter
bedroom and a 9.5 is meter study what's
to prevent uh what what what conditions
are in place or what uh enforcement
action can we take if that were to be
marketed as a uh two-bedroom property or
a one-bedroom with study stroke bedroom
so there are no condition in place
currently on the outline permission that
would prevent that property being
marketed as a two-bedroom property um
what would be in place on the reserve
matters are conditions that require
development to be in accordance with
plans um and the plans identify that as
a study rather than a bedroom so if
there were uh marketing efforts to
advertise that as a two-bedroom property
then that would arguably be a conflict
with the approved plans um and it would
be matter to consider whether or not um
enforcement action was uh prudent in the
Public's
interest okay and what would prevent
someone converting it to a bedroom once
they bought it as a one bed with
study and then reselling it as a two
bed uh nothing in the same way that
there's nothing to prevent people using
something advertised as a dining room as
a
bedroom so whether we like it or not the
mix could well be not what is being put
in in front of us
now although we have policies that seek
to control mix at the point we Grant a
planning permission once that permission
is granted we don't seek to retain that
mix in perpetuity unless they're
affordable
dwellings um so affordable houses
section 106 stipulates the mix that
should remain that mix in perpetuity but
as for Market housing once they're sold
people are at Liberty to um live in them
and occupy them as they see fit and we
don't usually control
that I've got one for Ben probably um on
that Junction with the private drive
it's not sorted yet there was a there
was a suggestion that if it wasn't
sorted you know more space would be
needed potentially to use it and the
design would alter and we'd have already
granted the permission um have you got
any comments on that just to clarify
first you mean the access to the
existing farm
buildings the the crossing of the main
road over the the
farm sorry I just wanted to clarify um
the original application came forward
was to maintain the private drive all
the way across to the existing farm
buildings and therefore it would cross
the carriageway the high Authority
considered that to be unsafe and
objected um and then has been in working
dialogue with Taylor wimp but also the
residents group to try and find a
solution the County Council put forward
to the solution that's seen in front of
you as a potential option which Taylor
Wimpy have worked up and we're just in
the process of reviewing the road safety
audit that has been
provided um it means that the private
Drive will no longer be able to be used
for those buildings with the um the
access becoming the use for the for any
traffic trying to access those buildings
we've got the vehicle tracking as well
and that's all currently being reviewed
um that's the position of the highway
Authority at the moment if we're happy
with all that as is in line with the
offerers recommendation and you are as
chair of the planning committee then um
permission can be granted obviously if
there isn't then we will speak to uh the
planning Authority in the first instance
to find out what we what are the next
steps can I ask what those next steps
might
be uh I guess once once we've had the
results of the road safety audit if if
there were an issue it would be with
your discretion to to refuse the consent
and say that you felt it was UN unsafe
at that point on the basis that we've
been through committee and right okay
good uh any other questions or can we go
to
debate want a break
now no we generally want to get on we
want to get on then we'll have a break
okay good so debate
so I've got concerns about uh the the
Aesthetics of this and um not not really
I think the the frontage on the Loxley
road is is okay for Taylor wimpy uh and
the front edge to the southern um
Recreation ground is okay for Taylor
wimpy I mean you know I say for tailor
wimpy but actually it's okay uh and I
don't think we could refuse it on that
once we get into the the Western portion
I think things do begin to get um
blander and the the the points made
about the single houses not you know
being being odd looking uh the single
dwellings being very narrow and out out
of place if you look at anywhere else uh
in the older portion of Stratford I
think that's that's true I think it does
seem to get very cramped when you get
down to the South um with with a lot of
sort of car parking you know it's like
Terraces and then a whole load of
parking in front of it um which which
doesn't look nice um there are there are
lookth throughs from the road which were
mentioned um which go straight up to um
the back of garages and fences at
Gardens which uh councelor Rolph
mentioned now we've heard that that
can't be avoided um but it could be
avoided it would mean losing a house and
putting in some Landscaping there in a
cycle access so that you didn't have to
go all the way around but you know you
can create nice things it's a question
of how much you try and cram in to a
space that that creates this sense of of
being surrounded by by by brick walls
and some of those some of those Corner
plots uh and the the blank walls I think
that's a valid point as well so I think
there is a question of poor design here
um so I'm just going to put that out
there I'm I'm not saying it's enough to
refuse it I'm thinking about it uh
cancel
Giles um I agree with your comments
councilor Carriage I think particularly
that portion of the site is incredibly
disappointing um all the guidance now is
so clear and I Council Rolf is
absolutely right about the new mppf it's
all about saying look in this country
there is an acceptance that we we are
having to house build and and that has
its consequences but to to offset and
balance that it needs to be high quality
it's emphasized all the way through that
and I think when we're sat here making
excuses for for um the mediocrity that
is here um that it's just not good
enough and actually it's not in
accordance with the guidance that we're
given which is to demand to demand the
best there there's just no reason why
all the time we sit here and say well
it's sort of okay okay then um I mean I
actually don't think um the frontages on
Loxley Road do come up to standard I
think it's not going to be
very I I I I accept what council R says
from her detailed working there's going
to be a disparity between the two sites
and that's not what we're looking for
we're looking for something which is
cohesive so certainly I am um um open to
refusal on the design aspects but I'm
certainly extremely open to the question
of a deferral to give the developer the
opportunity to engage in further talks
about these specific issues because I I
think even if we just look at some of
the very specific things so for example
when we look at plot plot 18 and 81 that
we were shed and that kind of you know
that it's one it's it's there's a degree
of prominence there because it's at the
end of a road and you just look at that
and think it just doesn't say anything
it's just so Bland I I do think the
density is a problem and I I do
appreciate that the de density has to be
taken to some degree from what the
inspector outlined but actually it does
say up to 270 houses it's not an exact
requirement and I think it might not
mean actually a lot of adjustment to
just add a sense of space I mean
obviously we can see in this part of the
site there is actually quite a pleasing
sense of space in the way that the
housing is round a curve but we get into
just people hitting house upon house
upon house it's just it's just so I
think there are design problems in terms
of the physical look of the house but
also in terms of the layout I think
there is something that needs to be done
and it might not need to be in a ma a
major adjustment and I think there needs
to be consideration to that I think the
connectivity is a disappointment you
know paragraph 17 sorry page 17 uh in
the report it's very clear the inspector
noted
that the extent of pedestrian and pych
links means that the scheme could
produce a high quality and
well-connected
Community I don't think any of us are
looking at this going yep that creates a
really well integrated Community you
know we've I'm not saying it's not a
challenge because you've got what is
permitted as being quite dense housing
stuck on the end of ribbon development
where there's quite a lot of sense of
space but there must be ways of making
that that connect better and the idea
that we've got this foot path that you
know is inadequate that leads us into
close I think that's very
unsatisfactory
um what can we say about housing mix I
mean yes we just have to accept accept
what we're told about that and I and
we've been given a very reasoned view on
that that that is incredibly
disappointing because the whole idea of
house building in Stratford upon aen
itself is to provide access to people uh
who can't afford to live in this market
ordinarily and when basically everything
is done to try to get round that it's um
very disappointing the end uh the
neighborhood plan is incredibly specific
it's should be given full weight um it's
it's either a real oversight of what
went on earlier and it's a huge there
should be some huge learning to take
from that or to be honest I would want
to know if there is something we can do
about that because you know that is that
apart from anything else it's not good
Community working um between developers
and communities um yeah to be honest I
could go
on okay
um councelor Richards thank you chair um
so look I I agree with what what both
yourself and councel JS have had to say
so far the on a design perspective you
mentioned um the um Aesthetics and
obviously I made the point that it's not
just about Aesthetics actually I think
Council R answered my question better
when she's when she responded to Council
of VRI and made the points that it's
about a connected coherent community and
we don't have this here we were looking
at what I asked a question of the the
applicant how much involvement have they
had with the splitfire group who are
bringing for the other half of the site
this is an entire site this is this is
one big site that is being brought
forward in a mix mix match way there is
no um uh cerent plan towards it there's
no sense of community there's no
bringing together of these properties
and it certainly doesn't fit in with the
street scene that we already have on the
Loxley Road we're going to have lovely
houses on Loxley Road a very small patch
of what appear to be reasonable uh
Spitfire designed and then a complete
mix of other designed properties um it
doesn't feel right to me it doesn't look
right to me I don't know if we're able
to uh have the two BR brought in
together I think it's a great shame that
they haven't been brought together um
but I do think it would be uh of of
value to this this committee and this
Council for both um
uh both applications to be heard at the
same time so we can understand from both
camps how they've brought this forward
how it's going to fit together how it's
going to become a community rather than
just a mix of uh of houses and
individual small developments scattered
around in one larger Site Area um I'm
happy to propose a deferral on that
basis um and if anyone else wants to add
anything to what I've said I'd be happy
to listen to it and if if appropriate we
can add it to it okay councilor Barnes
yes I feel it ain't
right cycle alwayss footways
design um and uh as I say the last
speaker
did speak about deferral and and I would
be happy to second that what I would say
is that under the
Constitution we had a site in Long
Master which we didn't like we went to a
senior officer here Jay sing who's gone
had a three-hour battle with the U
developers they came back with what we
wanted and under the Constitution it
doesn't have to come back to committee I
feel that that is the sort of thing that
we need to do here um maybe the same
officers but we use it separate opposite
and I would like if you wanted sometime
to go and look at this site because it's
nearly finished now and you know we all
agree that it's super so as far as I'm
concerned I'm quite happy for the
perment um for the reasons that's been
given um and I do feel that as we've got
two sides together I think that we
should come to a conclusion on both
sides at the same time if we could
whether that delays it or not I don't
know the other thing was that I would
have thought that at the appeal although
there's no words for the housing Mitch I
don't feel that they come up with the
core strategy as they did at the time
the appeal was looked at and as far as
I'm concerned that's the percentage that
I feel should be appropriate needs more
work doing on it I'm happy to Second
deferment okay now we just got to
remember we've got two applications here
I think we're certainly talking about
deferment which has been we've had a
second now um for the the housing aspect
of it uh we'll deal with that one first
we're also if we can hear from David um
first he has something to say as well
yeah thank you uh councelor Carriage I
just thought I'd take a moment to
interject members seem to be moving
towards um a vote on whether or not to
defer this application for further work
on design ground and um there has been
some discussion about uh deferral and
what situation ations would be
appropriate to defer um an
application um when when we come to
reach a resolution on a planning
application we have these options
available to us and um in some
circumstances we can overcome some
design concerns with conditions um and
in some circumstances it may be
appropriate for a deferral um where
there are a modest number of issues with
an application where it may be sensible
for planning officers to talk to the
applicant and see whether those issues
um are capable of being overcome um and
and then there is uh a level of concern
which perhaps suggests that there is a
reason for refusal
um from what I've heard from Members so
far uh I'm slightly concerned that we
may be falling into that last Camp we're
hearing that the layout is too cramped
that they haven't been providing us with
um cycle provision which we were seeking
um there are concerns with the
elevations um with layouts with the
approach to um open space um and overall
um a concern that that hasn't when
brought together provided us with um you
know a sense of place um to my mind that
doesn't sound like a reason for refusal
that sounds like a um a reason for
refusal um it's not not a reason for
deferral and and I think I'd um like
members to thank you very much councelor
councelor Richards first sorry so
something I I obviously there's a lot
going on from what we've heard today and
um one of the things I didn't get out
when I made my um proposal was that
actually if we were looking at this as
an independent site so if it wasn't part
of a wider scheme I'd be seeking a
refusal on the basis of the grounds I
put so I think actually you've you've
hit the nail on the head there one of
the reasons why I think it would be
useful to defer is that we do know that
there is um an application for the
essentially the other side of the road
the other half of the site and this is
an opportunity for Taylor wimpy to go
and work on this site and actually get a
potentially get an approval at an
earlier stage than if they were sent
away with a refusal and then had to
rework the entire site and come back um
now yeah have some comments on that m
I don't mind either way um a deferral
seems logical because it does mean we
get to see the other side at the same
time and that's part of the coherence
and and what have you if you if members
think that's inappropriate if you're
going to give us guidance to say that's
inappropriate I'm quite happy to move
towards a refusal I think I probably
should just give some guidance on that
so that's okay you will give some yeah
if I could just add to that um if you
can bring that that second reason which
has come out that we want to see them
both together if that's a valid reason
as
well I struggle to see that as a valid
reason um for a couple of reasons
obviously the um process which was gone
through following the outline permission
was to agree um a phasing scheme which
very clearly set out that these would be
presented to the planning Authority in
different phases so to my mind that set
expectations that we should be able to
consider these as separate
matters um secondly that there is
obviously National guidance and
requirements that we handle all planning
applications
expeditiously um I think deferring an
application uh with the intention to
engineer its return to committee
alongside another application would not
be seen as reasonable or good service to
the
applicant okay now very quickly we're
going to hear from councelor Barn it was
just a comment really about the big
walls on there if you got the Birmingham
Road there's a development on the left
hand side which they' got big walls I
said put tax windows in them the company
didn't even know what I meant but if you
go up there now you see where the old
windows used to be when the tax and they
took them out and they look beautiful in
that wall and that came from me and who
else it was okay so that's a can get
designed right if we refuse it and they
go to appeal we've got what we want and
that isn't what we want
counselor um I think the reality is that
I mean one of the difficulties with
deferral is that what we're not looking
for is minor modification potentially it
it looks as though we might be looking
for you know slightly greater
modification in terms of you know the
all the things and that you know we've
touched on and when you listen to those
collection of reasons collectively we're
frankly saying on a number of quite
significant you know heads we're not
happy with the scheme
okay coun I was just going to say on not
on that basis to be honest after having
heard that advice I would propose
refusal and and it would be for the
reasons that have been summarized um
there chairman sorry sorry councelor
hang we've already got a seconded
proposal to do yeah we've got to vote
through that first unless you you can
withdraw it yeah you can withdraw it
well don't mind withdrawing it or
changing it to a refusal so let's just
withdraw it it simp as you you've
withdrawn
CER ainson I always believed we should
judge an application as submitted that's
what our mandate is I think councelor
Barnes has suggested we have a site
visit if that is the case I'm pleased to
Second it because I believe it would be
of value to everyone who has not been to
the site which I would guess is the
majority of us uh well we've had a
propos I think we've sorry no we we've
we've had a proposal we've had the the
proposal to defer withdrawn so that I'm
afraid the second then Falls away
presumably we've had a proposal from
Council Giles to to refuse and a
seconder so we will now vote on
that okay and if that fails we can have
a site visit I don't think we need a
site visit because there's nothing there
it's just a field I don't think I propos
a site visit
sorry I I'll give you one comment
councelor V it is just for my I was
seeking some guidance
if obviously we the discussion earlier
on was an agreement by the developer to
accept a number of conditions so presume
if we were to Grant with conditions all
those get adopted if we were to vote to
reject this application do we put all
those potential new conditions at risk
it's in the hands then of the okay we
let's get some advice on that because I
I would suggest can because you know if
we do refuse it and it goes to appeal uh
which no doubt it would uh can we can
suggest to the can we can we can we do
that with officers and
chair um arrange the
conditions so yeah a couple of things if
uh the application was refused um and uh
the applicant came back in for uh
another go if you like uh to try and get
the details right then we would of
course be at Liberty to consider what
conditions would be appropriate on any
res commed application if they went to
appeal um we would defend our reason for
refusal but we would also provide
without prejudice a number of conditions
which the planning inspector would have
the opportunity to consider imposing if
he chose to Grant a planning
permission okay so under those
conditions are we happy we know why
we're refusing we've listed that quite
quite um considerably we have a vote
think just to
clarify well I'll um Molly do you want
to
clarify and just just on David's point
just then chair and and sorry if I I'm
get the way but just if could the
proposal and seconders confirm that they
would want without prejudice those
conditions to be part of that reason to
to refuse okay and the reasons and we're
going to counselor Giles so on that last
point
certainly um and so the re the reasons
for refusal are around um cs10 in the
neighborhood development plan with and
the um sorry yes and um the uh mppf
which is was all about high quality
design and in general terms this fall
short um it's going to be it would
appear that it's going to be in contrast
to further phases coming forward so
there is there's a lack of
cohesion um in specific terms there are
problems and in large terms I would
agree with the specific points that have
been put forward by councilor Rolf um um
they they largely those specifics seem
to have a lot of
validity I then
think uh on under another heading which
is separate from design is about um Co
well I mean I don't know whether it
would fall under the same thing but it's
to do with um the sense of space and the
density in that portion there
um then a third issue is around the
connectivity of the site lack of cycling
um um and the connectivity of the foot
waves particularly into is it wooden
close um and and how this site can con
how this whole site can connect well
into the into the community so so it's
it's
connectivity um councilor Richard
anything
else um you you got layout and density
didn't you so over
development and I think you said cs10 I
think you meant cs9
for um and is as I think as10 is a
design
related um
be1 okay councelor councelor Giles yes I
mean that sort of falls into the
specific raised by councilor Ral but but
certainly when we went into looking at
the the elevations they are well they're
not distinctive but all there just
doesn't seem to be coherent coherence
really to the design we're not not sure
what it's trying to say how it uh is is
coherent with the future phasing and the
existing existing phasing and and much
of it is actually just substandard so
for example one example would be plots
1881 it's just not good enough it is
just medoc and it's not good enough um
and and there are other examples within
the site of that yeah I think we've
discussed lots of specific um with those
and the the street scene when compared
to Loxy Road as
well
okay so
counselor um thank you chair just in
regards to the officer's recommendation
obviously it says we're waiting for the
highway authority to consider the road
safety audit for the uh the junction
into the Farm area if you are
considering refusal um because that
hasn't been determined yet I would
recommend as the highway officer that's
included in the list because it means
that that work can remain ongoing as
part of that and it means that it isn't
lost in the actual decision notice
because it's an outstanding matter and
the highway author does technically
still have an objection in place but
that's for you to consider well I
totally agree with that yeah I'm fine
with that as well we presumably can't
include anything about housing mix in
line with NDP and the the updated the
recently sorry adopted NDP and our
course strategy given what you said ear
I'd suggest not in terms of housing mix
just on lack of cycling are you sure you
want to put that given what the County
Council have said about cycling and how
this isn't the sort of development that
would have cycling
provision I think C J said connectivity
rather than specifically cycling
although on aren't we allowed to
stipulate sorry chair if you don't mind
but I'm going to stipulate the 3 meter
rather than 2 meter I know you say it's
not Pacific but because it it did say
cycling and pedestrian why can't we
identify what we think it should be
because it is ambiguous because it was
just I think we can add that as a note
frankly I don't think we can use it as a
reason for
refusal but I think I think we've made
it clear that you know what the what the
um what the planning inspector said
about it being uh having the potential
for uh uh quality development with
cycling and connectivity and all the
things that the the original Inspector
said which we don't feel have been met
um I think maybe we could wrap it up in
in that in a general sort of we we don't
think this meets what the inspector
envisaged you're absolutely
right right
so this is just
for we'll have to do this all again but
this is just for application
18258 2
Reem which is the reserve matters
application for 135 dwellings okay so we
all that all those in favor of refusing
this
application uh for the reasons given and
with the things about the conditions
attached um please vote
now six uh all those against
refusing all those abstaining one Obion
thank you so this Commission comme has
resolved to refuse application 1802 582
RM now we go under the Landscaping one
um can we I don't know can we have
some comment on that uh I see no reason
why we
can't it might make sense not to agree
it well there're certainly separate
considerations um the applications uh
need to be considered on their own
merits um clearly the uh shape and
Arrangements of um soft and hard
Landscaping features within the proposal
um are related to uh the housing
proposal can I jump in there can we just
refuse it on lack of information as we
don't know what's going around
it I think you'd have to be specific
about what information was required um
and was
absent cancer child well the difficulty
is is
that in Practical terms if adjustments
needed to be made to that landscaping
and potentially not controversial ones
that weren't controversial to the
applicant or to the council it might be
quite difficult if we've approved it
because if they had to change if they
wanted to change their layout or
resubmit and then they were this
landscape plan is fixed in stone it it
it presents a lot of practical
difficulties I would suggest it just
seems ridiculous to approve something
there I completely the is it could well
constrain any future design and layer of
the site um which is a problem for
Taylor wimpy there we go that sounds
like a reason so yeah if that is a valid
reason then I'm entirely comfortable
with it councel VRI I just going to say
the alternative is potentially seek
advice but to defer it because there's
there's not much point I agree we
shouldn't approve it certainly that
would be my view but one could also
defer it on the basis that hopefully the
developer will be pragmatic
okay well I think deferment is the right
thing because for simple thing it may
have to be changed when they change the
houses as far as I'm concerned I'm quite
happy to propose deferment on this part
of the
application okay I know it's it's an odd
situation to be uh it does seem
ridiculous to to Grant it we don't want
to Grant it uh for the obvious reasons
that you know we don't we don't want to
to to to bind any future development on
this site uh do we defer or do we
um refuse refuse I'm looking for for
some advice one moment shall we have
that um break you want just one moment
no
e
okay and
David yeah um taking members back a
stage obviously we have agreed um
through the outline permission um a
parameters plan which sets out broadly
the areas of public open space and
Landscaping which are going to need to
be complied with by any development
um officers uh in considering the
reserve matters proposal for those
details consider that a reasonable
response to those parameters plans and
not withstanding members refusal of the
um uh Reserve matters for the Housing
Development maintain that that is a
reasonable response to um to the outline
permission and a reasonable way of
moving forward in seeking Reserve
matters approval for the Landscaping
elements of the open
space
um in that sense uh it would be sensible
for members to uh reach conclusion in
our view in in respect of the
Landscaping proposals um we think our
recommendation remains sound okay so
recommendation to approve even so
councilor
Barnes I was just sort of going to ask a
question are we saying that the
Landscaping
goes the way that the appeal went and if
that's the case then we asked up with
the approve of it okay councilor Richard
so yeah so um having made the comment
that uh are we tying the developers
hands there more I thought about while
are you deliberating actually there's
nothing to stop developer putting
forward either a um an amended plan or a
another plan anyway that would supersede
what we potentially could be granting or
refusing now so on that basis and on
what the basis of what you've just said
that it does tie in with what was um
approved it appeal in the outline um
then I propose that we do Grant the
Landscaping element of this okay counc
chares um the only thing I did actually
want to know about this was the tree and
Landscape officer made a number of
comments and then sorry no no no you
finish honestly that's fine if
you sorry I I was I was just conferring
with um
Vicki having having looked again what
strikes me is that there are perhaps
elements of the out the proposed Reserve
matters in the public open space which
um may have influence on uh members
views in terms of
connectivity
um um whether that falls to members to
to judge how they determine the de we
are going back and
forth
Sor um okay well we'll come back to that
in a minute when we've had a chance to
digest that but the only other thing I
did actually want to know is the tree
and Landscape officer had various
comments actually on the landscape plan
including about Native mix the applicant
responded to that with additional
proposals did the tree landscape officer
have the chance to look at those
resubmitted proposals and provide any
comment
she has um she hasn't seen the full
Suite of additional details that have
been submitted in the last few days but
they have addressed all of the issues
that that she raised but no she hasn't
that's been me making that assessment
that's not been her making the
assessment well I
mean I Pro propos you very I'm quite
happy to I'm speaking okay um if if you
did wish to defer there were a number of
conditions that were suggested uh in
relation to the Landscaping scheme
including bards and other matters and
how it would be managed I don't think it
would be unreasonable to maybe consider
a deferral to understand how we would
deal with those conditions um we've had
a we've had a proposal for deferral and
and a proposal to
uh yeah we've certainly had a proposal
to defer I'm going to look for a second
uh to
defer to look at all the conditions
we've talked of to consider connectivity
and actually the reality of this in you
know in relation to they not being a
granted application anymore um is I'll
second that well I was going to say yes
I mean I would have seconded that and
and the reason is because it's a proper
to be honest it's a proper reflection of
our our views which is we don't have a
problem necessarily with it but having
said that we don't have enough
information because actually it's it's
totally intertwined with any other
application and particularly the
connectivity and how and the space
issues and so without seeing the two
together it is very difficult to make a
judgment I think there are some is some
outstanding information so that's part
of the outstanding information
understanding how this application would
inter leave with any further application
so yes okay so I seconded it sorry
you've commented it you've proposed it
we're going to have a vote on deferring
for for more information on on on
on some of the things we talked about
conditions and and because it represents
what we think about you know we we need
to know how this actually does relate to
what's going to be there in future okay
we happy with that uh all those in favor
of
deferring that's unanimous chairman okay
love so we're doing that and we're going
to take a break for 10 minutes only 10
minutes we will be back at 252 when we
will begin
you
e
sorry about that uh now there has been
uh what might be termed a mistake in the
agenda um we've got item number nine
right at the end uh which is uh the land
to the rear of uh littlewood Green in
Studley uh that's been deferred or gone
for a side visit twice already and as
we're getting on in time at halfast 9 we
will have to have a vote to see if we do
carry on or not uh and there's a
possibility that we don't so I don't
want that to happen to that application
again so I'm
bringing the studly application forward
to the next item and then we will
continue the um agenda as before now
I've made comments um against this
application so I won't be sitting as
chair and councelor Giles will be
sitting in on this
one
good evening if I could invite the offic
to make the presentation thank
you thank you chair good evening uh this
is a full plan application for the
erection of five dwellings and
Associated works and the demolition of
an existing double garage uh this
application site is within the main Ro
Center of Sudley as illustrated by this
black dot on the
plan this is an aerial view of the
application site uh signified by the red
arrow uh one can see the proposed
development is to the rear of Lords Lane
and litw green and it's a short distance
from the a 448 bromsgrove
Road uh here we have the submitted site
location plan which shows the
application site in more detail uh one
can see that access is gained uh is
proposed to be gained off Lords Lane uh
here uh VI an existing
access um here we see the submitted uh
proposed site layout plan uh one can see
the proposed footing of the five
dwellings uh here uh in addition to the
car and cycle parking uh provision uh
one can also see the vehicle turning
area here um in addition to the proposed
bin store areas for the dwellings
proposed to be located
here um here we see the proposed
elevations uh they're proposed to be two
storage gabled properties with pitched
roofs uh and comprise four semi-detached
properties and one detached
uh and they comprise of two and three
bedroom uh
properties um sorry if I skip back a
second uh one can see the proposed Ridge
uh for the detached property here uh is
set down from the proposed Ridge height
for the two of the four of semi detached
properties uh in the middle and on the
far right um the proposed materials are
to be facing brick work and concrete T
Roofing uh for the detach property
here uh and the semi- detach PLS plots
uh for four and five yeah uh the
proposed middle uh two semi properties
are proposed to be rendered block workk
and concrete tole
roof uh here we now look at some site
photos um one can see the here we are
stood pipon on the uh South Eastern end
of the Lords Lane looking northwestwards
um one can see the proposed point of
access gained through here which we'll
see a further close up in a second but
you can get an idea of the uh
residential C nature that this site is
currently situated within
uh here we are now stood at the point of
proposed access um looking
southwestwards uh one can see the uh
rear of number 3A bromsgrove Road
here here we are stood facing uh the
western part of the site at the rear of
the properties along lwood green uh one
can also see the overgrown current
nature of the site in its existing form
uh here we are now stood at the Northern
end of the site looking South southwards
uh one can see the proposed garage
element here hopefully uh um which is
proposed to be demolished uh as part of
this proposal uh there's also partly
sorry big upon here there's also the
electricity substation here which is
outside of the red line boundary um and
here we are said in the middle of the
application site looking southeastwards
uh where one can see the uh rear
elevations of the Lords Lane
properties um that's my that concludes
my presentation chair um just say that
on the uh update sheet um there is a
brief summary of the members site visit
that took place on Friday the 30th um as
was uh as was the decision of the
previous committee um chair my
recommendation is to Grant the
application for the Reon set out Pages
99 and 100 of your agendas thank
you um if I could now invite councelor
Eden uh to speak thank
you thank you councelor you have three
minutes and you'll be given a 30 second
warning thank you you good evening uh
Studley Parish Council would like to
reiterate its objections to this
application on the grounds of
overdevelopment a lack of parking in
particular the concerns surrounding
emergency waste Vehicles emergency and
waste vehicles to the site the solution
to the latter will require a management
company to be set up to handle the
resident waste collection this is
neither appropriate nor reasonable and
will be un unenforceable excuse me
whilst also placing an unfair
disadvantage on residents who will have
to pay council tax for Council Services
then another service charge to the
management company to include the cost
of the
collections further to this it will also
be impossible to enforce highways
request that yellow lines are instored
around the entrance to the site to
prevent parking and to keep the access
clear the issue being that most of the
road where lines will be installed is
unadopted in addition we would like to
reiterate that the design of the
properties is Bland and devoid of any
interest and the properties are cramped
and with minimal immunity space contrary
to SDC design
guides also as there are no alternative
parking opportunities close to the site
visitors will have no option other than
parking on the access road which will
create friction between existing
residents and
newcomers we are also concerned that
with the properties being aimed at
family homes this will mean there will
be children living there and we are
concerned there's no safe foot path into
the site until you get on to Lord's
Lane we understand that the landlord
also holds the lease for the garages
that are on the rightmost entrance to
Lord's Lane and the Terrace of cottages
on littlewood green so there's nothing
to stop them negotiating a new agreement
to demolish the garages that are there
improve the road into the site and build
replacement garages within the site that
would create a safe entrance and and
excellent visibility and have no impact
on parking in the rest of the road
members will see the uh the restrictions
that exist with parking in Lord's Lane
and and their visit will have been at
the time when the majority of residents
are at work each block of flats has four
flats each having two bedrooms a
conservative estimate would mean there
will be at least four vehicles per PL
per block but that could easily double
when there's only room for two or three
cars outside the property leaving
residents no option but to park half on
the path half on the road making access
to the site very
difficult the parish council supports
this site being bought forward for
housing but not if the properties are
built of such poor design come with
inherent problems with waste collection
and will cause considerable conflict
with the existing residents over parking
an appropriate is possible but that will
involve the applicant entering into
negotiation with their leaseholders just
because they've not done so yet doesn't
mean we should go against the basic
planning principles to get it through we
urge the committee to reject this
application the reasons stated are clear
and members can easily match the
relevant policies to the reason has
provided thank you any
questions no thank you very
much
so we don't have anyone on behalf of the
applicant so if I could now invite
councelor right to
speak um Council right you have five
minutes and you'll be given a 30 second
warning okay thank you the MPP F
paragraph
118 discusses the effective use of land
and suggests the use of minimum density
standards and states that the
opportunity should be taken to achieve
net environmental
gains the appearance of overdevelopment
with access restrictions which the
parish council have outlined you does
not suggest environmental
gain the Strategic objective in our core
strategy strategic objective three
discusses the need for new developments
to be of high quality
design page 90 in the report refers to
the nppf likewise and nppf paragraph 124
states that good design is a key is a
key aspect of
sustainability with sustainable
development I accept that this
development can be supported by local
servicer however not in any document
does it say at any at any price an
overdevelopment is not good design stud
the parish council sbor Parish Council
and other objectors have recognize this
and nobody denies that the site does
need to be developed but not with this
one paragraph
113 that permission can be refused for
development to pause design and you've
actually just done that that fails to
take the opportunity to improve the
character and quality of the area
paragraph 131 of the mppf states apart
from promoting sustainability it should
help to raise the standard of design and
the area more generally in the area it
does not say it should accept mediocre
or poor quality that may surround a
project prior to occupation three
conditions are laid out if these have to
be considered before occupation does not
common sense tell you that problems
already exist every day we see the
consequences on nearly every road of
parking and the problems it creates the
parkings of these dwellings should not
be considered in isolations these houses
will be part of the community local C
ownership should be considered as most
of then need the car to get to work and
the number of cars will increase in that
area and having difficulties with a
local
area again all the obors have drawn this
your attention the issue of
accessibility to the site so it is
recognized locally involved as an and
involved as an issue and a major problem
in Lord's Lane I don't know where you
got those photographs but I've never
seen it as empty as that new Bud should
enhance an area not to help to intensify
the problems in Lords Lane nothing
should be made worth and policy cs9 a
state in the report should enhance the
quality of the place and enhancement is
not demonstrated but the potential for
worsening the situation can be
anticipated highway state in the report
that it is likely to impact on the
Strategic Road Network that's not the
issue the issue is parking and the use
of the ex the exit on Lord's Lane to
this site clear
C that's acknowledged if if refug
lorries can't get up it and they have to
stand at the bottom or we have to pay
there is a real issue about
it and how long would an agreement about
Refuge collection last the entire life
of a house is over a hundred years old
as a rule so you know we have to ask who
will be there to reinforce it in years
to
come in the rec recommendations it lays
out pre
commencement condition and refers to
water drainage condition I am very aware
of the flooding problems that have
current occurred down there we more than
the potential for an engineering
engineering solution we to need to know
exactly about the potential and it's
exactly how this will be resolved the
other conditions does suggest before
planning M given is for this stand
further should discussion should be
taking place because there are still a
lot of questions to be asked 30 seconds
again I would ask that the quality
design principles are applied to raise
standards and enhance the area not to
continue mediocre development for which
accessibility is an
issue um and doesn't really do much to
support
sustainability I feel that's as much as
I want to say so my issues are
accessibility poor design
and the combination of the problems it
will bring in the
future thank you very
much the committee have any
questions thank you Council
right any technical
questions councelor Oran um thank you
chair um the parking on site does it
comply with the new draft parking
standards uh yes thank you um I can
confirm that um the applicants have
actually provided one additional space
more than they were actually required to
under the new uh well the draft parking
standards um there are sorry there are
there are five dwellings which they need
to provide a minimum of 10 um there's
also um Vista parking allowance
incorporated into that so they're needed
to provide a minimum of 12 and they've
provided 13 in this
submission um if I can ask I don't
suppose you can just help me a little
bit more with with the design and the
appearance of these properties um you
talked about concrete tiled Roofing and
rendered block work are you able to just
give me a bit more of a description
about what that
means
like yes I can indeed um it's that
that's been um communicated in the uh
applicants design access statement
submission um that would be fairly
typical materials um for the setting of
the area I mean I'm sure welome to
matters of design if you wish to debate
that going forward um I do believe there
is um that is something that could um be
potentially secured by condition also um
potentially DET schedule of materials
and matters relating to exact details um
and samples um to satisfy offices that
that is um being built out in the
acceptable standard so what rendered
block work I mean is it do we know what
sort of what color it will look like I
mean is it what is it so none of this is
Brick is it it won't it's all
just yeah the the uh there will be some
brick work itself the rendered element
is this middle section here on this
proposed these These are the front
elevations of the five dwellings uh the
detached dwelling here there are two
semis here and then the further two
semis there um in an efforts uh I
believe to sort of break up the the the
um design somewhat um the applicants
have set down this dwelling but there's
also so this this element here this
attached delling will be brick work as
well these two here uh this element here
is proposed to be rendered um with uh
with the same tiles I believe proposed
for all three but this element
specifically here in the middle will be
uh posed to be
rendered um so sorry just I come to in a
minute councelor barns um so obviously
what's been raised is really the design
is mediocre and it's not doing anything
to enhance the character of the area I
mean what what would your justification
be in terms of whether this complies
with what we're looking for from a
design
perspective I think I me surely scs9
design element clearly we all seeking to
get the highest quality design possible
um in this particular location um and I
think for the benefit of members who
attended the site as well site visit as
well to get a wider appreciation of The
Wider area I would say there isn't a um
necessarily uh signature Design Elements
to the immediate area there is something
of a variance um of of the area um and
that's been communicated in the recent
submission uh in your agendas
um generally of course as as councelor
councel right has has claimed we we are
seeking to get a development here that
isn't
um seeking to perpetuate poor design if
if there is poor design elsewhere um not
withstanding um its officers view um
that the design elements specifically of
this proposal um are acceptable um as
it's been um detailed in in the agenda
um I'm not sure given the the the length
of time obviously this this under the
umbrella of this application this was
originally a scheme for eight dwellings
it's since gone down to uh five that's
been presented to you this evening um
there's clearly been um revisions and
and whatnot so I'm not sure
um where we to go back to the the
applicant and and and mention M of
design I'm not sure what more we would
would achieve but I don't know if if
David wishes to mention anything on that
yeah I think given the context of the
area what we're looking at here is a
scheme for a number of dwellings which
are you know admittedly simple but
appropriate uh councelor Barnes I was
just checking which was not going to be
brick when you asked about
clading s brick no no they're not all
brick um the pair in the center of the
front elevation there um will be
rendered yeah that's right yeah okay
councilor ainson yeah it's for five
dwellings there are like two semis are
they clust as four dwellings or is it
one
structure
um yes there there are there are four
four of the five proposed are semi
detach so these two here are semi as are
these two here and there's one detached
element here
um there are four structures there three
yeah they are three this is the proposed
Frontage here so we've got one uh plots
one two three and four and five this
here is a side elevation um so that
there are just three structures if you
like comprising five dwellings yeah so
the uh semis have clust as two houses
into one
structure uh yes yeah
correct um and then just finally for me
it was raised about immunity space I
just wondered if you could could give us
a sense of what what is going on there
particularly if some of these may end up
being family
homes yes I can indeed yeah um I've
actually I've also got some U
measurements in terms of the provision
of garden space if that will help um so
if we were to call this plot one um um
essentially the broad headlines are all
of these five dwellings uh exceed the
minimum standards for garden space uh to
all function sustainably as family homes
uh plot one has provision of
approximately 97 square meters um plot
two is 52 square meters here uh 76
square meters for plot Number Three uh
124 square met for plot Number Four and
103 square m plot Number Five the
minimum space standards are uh according
to our meeting house needs supplementary
guidance um it's minimum of 40 square
meters for a uh a two bed and a minimum
of 50 for a three bed so in all cases
they exceed the minimum
standards anybody else no thank you very
much so if I open up to
debate councilor Barnes yes I went on
the S visit um with George uh we did
have a job to park in Lords Lane to
cisac it was full of cars even at 3:00
in the
afternoon um and there was obviously a
car in the entrance um but that's not a
planning reason uh because there was no
highways
objection
um the five houses is a reasonably big
plot um but as far as I can the the
design really there wasn't
any uh all the has around there were
different I appreciate that but to me
there was no thought to the design at
all there was adequate room or just
about room for five was a an area of you
know houses next door to each other and
across the road it was an empty bit of
gr which had been left um and it would
it does need development but I do feel
that what's put forward in my eyes in
design terms is has had no thought
whatsoever put into
it anyone
else um well my thoughts are
um I think it uh in terms of over
development I think it's just about
acceptable I think it's it's probably on
the borderline but I think there's there
is good immunity I think there's
relatively good immunity space and
certainly when we're looking at in the
context of the area um I you know it's
difficult to quibble when there is
parking provision that's been made
available over and
above um what is recommended but I have
to say I am concerned with the design
it's difficult to
see what commends it I mean I suppose
simple is a diplomatic word um you could
say un inspiring and and as councilor
Barn says it doesn't appear that really
any thought has been put into it it's
just I don't know really so it's it's
difficult to feel passionate about
granting the application there are my
thoughts I don't know what anyone else
thinks um so I I take your point it is
quite plain in terms of design but then
when you look at the surrounding area um
it generally is relatively in keeping
with what's there and if you start
putting too uh much emphasis on fabulous
passionate design it's going to stick
out like a sore
thumb um almost make people in other
houses might maybe feel inferior
it it segregates a community you need to
be making the community as we've already
discussed cohesive and well a community
um
so I have no particular issue with it I
think as you've you've rightly pointed
out it's not an overd development the
side it actually fits quite well there's
adequate parking it's not uncommon for
uh sites to be subject to a management
uh committee particularly in terms of
Refuge certainly I've lived in similar
sort of uh compounds um I I'm entirely
happy with the officer's report and I
would recommend that we Grant and I make
that as a formal
proposal I have a second of that Road's
empty now but it was actually full of
3:00 in the afternoon um but all my
concern about was the
design no thought in my eyes and I was
glad I went on a site visit because it
does need something in
there Council ainson I went as Council B
on the site visit we parked without any
major problem there is capacity on the
site to take adequate parking without
any hesitation as far as design is
concerned well I can't see anything
wrong with it unless you're so
accustomed to
Spitfire uh arrangements as was
mentioned earlier you may get a bit of a
contrast but to me it's perfectly all
right uh there is as I say no trouble on
parking The Refuge issue has been taken
care of and let's not forget that there
was an appeal a successful appeal a few
years ago for something which was
relatively similar to this I think uh
Council Richard is right there's nothing
wrong with it if he's proposed it I'm
happy to Second his
proposal um just before I take a vote on
The Proposal that we have um condition
had been mentioned that materials are
put before offices um and in particular
so I think it if committee are minded to
Grant it it would be important that for
example the brick is good quality um
because there's obviously going to be a
lot of brick work on this site and um I
think that would be important and
generally for officers to be satisfied
that the materials are of a of a good
standard um I I don't know whether the
proposer would object to that condition
being added if it's not there
already um I've got no problem with it
being added I thought it was already on
there
but yeah I'm entirely happy for it to be
added if it's not and I trust officers
make to make an appropriate decision on
the quality of the
materials certainly it would be
reasonable to add a condition requiring
material
sample okay so committee we have a
proposal to um Grant this application um
with the addition of that condition um
all those in
favor all those against four in favor
two again thank you um this committee
proposes to Grant the application
resoles resolves I knew I got the
wording wrong resolves to Grant the
application thank
you
okay so uh on to the next application uh
180216 4 luc's Farm pord Lane wooden
woren and Charlotte dicks to explain
please thank
you thank you
chairman the site is indicated on the
map by the black circle the application
site is located to the east of wenwen
within the open Countryside it is
accessed via a single track from
pettiford
Lane this slide shows the application
site edged in red the site would
continue to be accessed from pord Lane
and currently features a two story pitch
Reef property with gardenland
surrounding within the red line there's
also a gr T listed Bridge which crosses
the canal the canal is shown by the blue
lines the site also features um two
agricultural buildings located directly
to the north the site is within the West
Midlands green bout as well as the ardan
special landscape area the pink line
shown to the west of the site indicates
the conservation area whilst the dotted
green lines to the Northeast and
southwest of the site indicate a public
RightWay this is an application for full
planning permission for a replacement
dwelling and Associated
Landscaping the slide shows the existing
block plan on the top of the screen with
a zoomed in version of the proposed
sighting of the new two-story property
on the bottom of the
screen this slide shows the existing
floor plans on the top of the screen
with the proposed floor plans shown
below these are replicated at slightly
different scales but do help to
illustrate that the floor space of the
dwelling would increase from 87 squ M up
to 208 square
m this slide shows the existing and
proposed front elevations at the top of
the screen with the existing and
proposed Southwestern side elevations
below please note that these are
replicated at slightly different scales
the dwelling would feature a main
pitched roof with additional Gable
features and an Engle chimney it would
be Timber framed with red
brick this slide shows the existing and
proposed northeast side elevations at
the top and the existing and proposed
rear elevations on the bottom of the
screen again shown at slightly different
scales a balcony is proposed on the rear
elevation this slide shows the gray T
listed humpback bridge in the foreground
um showing the access driveway towards
the existing dwelling the agricultural
buildings can be seen in the
background this photo is taken moving
further along the driveway Facing East
toward towards the existing dwelling
which is visible here the open field
surrounding the site and sty wood Beyond
can be
seen this photo is taken from the front
of the existing dwelling the edge of the
nearest agricultural building is visible
on the left hand side of the photo with
pastur land and Woodland
Beyond this photo is taken from the rear
of the existing building with the
agricultural buildings visible on the
right hand side of the
photo
this photo is again taken from the rear
of the dwelling facing south towards the
Open
Fields this photo is taken from the rear
facing west towards the canal and
pettiford Lane Beyond this shows the
existing side garden and the existing
boundary hedge just to clarify there's
one update within the update sheet
officer recommendation is to refuse the
application for full planning permission
for the reasons and note which can be
found on pages 50 57 and 58 of the
agenda thank you thank you very much we
will now hear from uh supporters and uh
objectors actually I don't think there
there are any oh yes there are okay so
uh the parish council councelor Mark
mcco chair of wooden waren Parish
Council hello and you have three
minutes good
evening I'll try not to be too
long um yeah Parish Council are happy to
support the application at luc's
Farm um I got a few photos which I took
uh on a site visit which might be
helpful um whilst the proposed
development is larger than the existing
building um we don't feel it's out of
scale with the nearby farm buildings you
can see the farm buildings on the back
right hand corner of those uh my
colleague there with his face blocked
out is uh standing roughly in the corner
of where the new building would be um if
you flip on a a couple more photos to
have a look at um we've marked out
roughly there um with the black and
yellow tape where the new um plot is for
the new
building um the new building fits nicely
within the plot it's within the boundary
hedge if you flip onto the next photo I
think you'll see the boundary hedge on
the left
oh is it just those two on there you can
see the boundary h on the left and the
proposed house fits well within the
boundary hedge that's there at the
moment uh without needing to remove any
trees or Hedges or anything like
that uh and they new property will
utilize the hard standing area in front
of the current property um for parking
so no extra um parking area is needed I
don't think um it seems most of the
neighbors seem to be in support of the
application um the site isn't
particularly overlooked by any other
properties um or foot paaths so it have
limited impact on the rural
character uh the existing white building
which I'm sure you'll agree um we feel
has a much greater negative impact on
the rural character than the proposed
new building of brick and Timber build
timber frame which is much more in
character with the neighboring farm
buildings uh next
door
and there's been much to mention of the
quality of design um here this evening
and we the parish council feels that the
proposed development is of a high
quality um it's quite a good good-look
building and it's a sort of uh
development that should be
encouraged um one of the comments um the
planning officer made was about the
glazing there's a lot of glazing on the
Southeast
elevation uh which looks out across the
field um and to the Woodland at the back
um so again it's not overlooked um by
anybody um we don't feel that that would
cause any harm to the um rural
character the current building uh isn't
utilized at all it's completely run down
um the parish council feels that making
use of the knocking down and building a
family home would make much better use
of the of the property I'm afraid that's
your 3 minutes was it I didn't get 30
second
warning yeah that's it uh what were you
just about to say by the way can I ask
you that I just kind of say that yeah
makes a the new property would make a
much more sustainable Family Home and
it's close to the
Village okay thank you uh councelor
ainson one of the comments of the
officers is about parking in the report
actually and that it would increase more
now I believe the agricultural buildings
behind are still active so you get
parking of agricultural vehicles and
there was at one time I think a costume
P company is that still there because
parking occurred when that so there's no
difference basically in what is being
utilized now and what the proposed
dwelling will create um as far as
parking as far as parking is concerned
as far as I understand it's going to use
the existing okay thanks just k
v you didn't refer to the green belt
your comments or the parish council's
comments about the impact on the Green
Belt um we feel that
the um I mentioned the Improvement in
the character of the building although
it is slightly larger than the existing
building it's going to look far better
than what's there now so we think it
would be an
improvement uh Cas bars Did you sort to
say it was in sustainable to the Village
or did I get that wrong yes it's
um it it needs to increase in size from
what's there currently to to be a
sustainable family home it's um probably
about half a mile to the local shop so
it's within walking distance to the
school bus
stop okay any other questions thank you
very much no problem uh and we will now
hear from
objectors uh
uh who have six minutes it's Daniel
Robinson I believe uh from Wells
planning very good you have six minutes
if you need
them thank you chair for the opportunity
to speak it's Dan Robinson Wells from
Marin's
planning on behalf of uh Mr Keeley I
endorse the office's recommendation to
refuse this proposal having reviewed the
plan submitted it is considered that the
proposal is contrary to the core
strategy National planning policy and
other local guidance and should
therefore be
refused principally the proposed
development is contrary to policy cs10
Green Belt of the core
strategy this policy and the nppf state
that the replacement building should not
materially be larger than the one the
one it
replaces the replacement dwelling
represents 140% increase in footprint
157% increase in volume and 18% increase
in Ridge height it's clearly materially
larger building and therefore is
inappropriate development within the
green
belt planning permission should
therefore only be granted in very
special
circumstances and local planning
authorities should ensure that
substantial weight is given to any harm
to the green belt
in this case the harm is significant in
that the replacement building is more
than doubling in size and is changing to
a substantial property to put this into
context the minimum National Space
standards for a six-bedroom 8 person
two-story dwelling is a floor space of
132 square m the proposed replacement
dwelling has a floor space of 332 square
meters very special circumstances will
not exist unless the potential harm to
the green belt by reason of
inappropriateness and any of the harm
resulting from that proposal is clearly
a way outweighed by other
considerations it is argued that the
that the applicant could extend the
dwelling under its P permitted
development rights and that this should
be taken into account when considering
whether the proposed replacement
dwelling is materially larger that is
incorrect application of green belt
policy the proposed dwelling is clearly
materially larger than the exist
existing dwelling and therefore is in
appropriate development as defined by
policy
cs10 the applicant has advised that the
existing dwelling is not suitable for
retention and no longer fit for purpose
there cannot therefore be a real
prospect that the applicant will extend
the existing building if they are
adamant it cannot be
retained on the basis of the evidence
available there seems little if any
prospect that the applicant will extend
the dwelling as described
if permission is refused it is noted
that the case officer does not consider
that the fallback position is legitimate
either the applicant has put forward
other arguments that it considers a very
special circumstances the relative
quality of the existing building to the
proposed replacement dwelling does not
amount to very special circumstances nor
does propose tree planting these would
be requirement of other policies in the
development plan in any event and do not
amount to very special circumstances the
economic benefits arising from the
construction of the replacement dwelling
would be very
limited therefore very special
circumstances have not been demonstrated
and planning permission should be
refused on the grounds of conflict with
policy cs10 and green belt policy within
the framework I therefore respectfully
request that you refuse planning
permission as recommended thank
you thank you very much uh are there any
questions can
bars are you a neighbor or how far away
are you see I'm a planning agent I'm
representing Mr key who uh lives within
the
village okay caner
Atkinson name sir if you don't mind Mr
Dan Dan Robinson Wells no oh M the the
the um the objector is Mr key ke and he
lives in the village yes is that the
large uh so it's it's
Yes Man I mean you you you give very
little weight to the economic benefit
that is one of the five principles
is in development it it quite is there
but I mean I think looking at any
planning um inspector's decision on a
scheme like this um I think the
inspector would also give it little way
and it would be refused hands down okay
thank
you well indeed yeah absolutely good any
other questions no thank you very much
and we now move to the applicants
agent uh Allison clar Oh no just a
minute that's wrong I'm on the wrong
page yes that's a bit of a
shock
right where where are
we I need to be on the right page
here planning yes three
minutes have I started I'm going to
about start you can start when you
want the core strategy states that
proposals for replacement dwelling in
the green belt should not cause material
I.E significant harm to the openness and
car of the area and that proposal should
be considered on a caseby casee basis in
this case the proposals do not cause
harm indeed they would enhance the site
and the local landscape and contribute
towards the character and equality of
the
district the existing dwelling is of
poor construction and of no
architectural Merit although the
existing dwelling could be renovated and
extended under permitted development
rights if necessary this is not the most
viable or sustainable option furthermore
it would not create the high quality
environment sought by the
council the existing dwelling would be
replaced with a high quality building of
traditional design and appearance with
exposed timber frame facing bricks and
plain clay roofing ties this reflects
the character and distinctiveness of the
locality the new dwelling would be of
sustainable construction with high
levels of Energy Efficiency and
performance it would be on the site of
the existing one the existing domestic
curtilage would not be
extended the proposed parking area is
the same as the existing dwelling it is
on an area of hard standing next to the
farm buildings The Proposal would not be
prominent in the landscape it would be
in proximity to and be seen in the
context of the existing substantial farm
buildings which are owned by the
applicant further the site is a
significant distance from public Vantage
points the canal toe path is a minimum
of 330 uh Metter to the north Norwest
and the public foot path to the east is
about 630 M away there is no public
access to the land to the south of the
site the glazing on the rear elevation
faces away from the public foot paaths
this glazing element is an attractive
feature and one which has been used on
all of the developments in the
locality the overall scheme uh as shown
on the plan uh displayed now
incorporates extensive new Woodland and
other tree planting on the applicants
land
these proposals would enhance the local
environment and the landscape qualities
of the area furthermore they would
produce a net gain in terms of
biodiversity in summary the scheme
achieves the objectives C of the council
to secure a high sustainable sorry a
high quality sustainable development and
to enhance the character and quality of
the district I believe the scheme is
appropriate development in the green
belt and that it Accords with policy CS
10 and the development management
considerations that go along with that
however if you disagree I submit the
considerations of outlined tonight and
put forward with the application do
amount to very special circumstances
sufficient for you to Grant planning
permission thank
you uh thank you very much councelor
Richards thank you you mentioned the
farm buildings that are in the uh
applicant ownership has consideration
been given to either uh redeveloping
those into a property or potentially I
presume they're no longer used as
agriculture they are a so they are still
used as agricultur the the applicant
Farms um 780 acres in this area and also
manages ay wood um so those farm
buildings are still in agricultural use
they're not livestock buildings they're
storage grain stores that sort of thing
um so that opportunity doesn't exist so
we needs them then thanks councilor
Giles just on I can be clear are you
saying that you accept that this is
inappropriate development in the green
belt because you accept its material
logg and therefore there are very
special circumstances or you claiming
that this isn't materially larger I'm
I'm saying that in accordance with
policy
cs10 um the requirements is to consider
the degree of harm the explanation to
policy CS 10 and the development
management considerations that go with
it set down a number of key factors to
be considered one of which is that the
dwelling should not be materially larger
but it then goes on to consider the
relationship of the proposal to other
buildings the qualitive
design and in my view um when you're
looking to assess the materiality of the
increase you have to consider all of
those site specific factors as you well
know the core strategy uh dropped the
what is referred to as the arbitrary 30%
limit and therefore we are looking very
much on on a Case by casee basis so I'm
saying I believe it to be appropriate
but if you disagree with me I think
there are very special
circumstances one more from councelor
Giles do you agree because one of the
things that you've been at pains to
emphasize is that this is a proposal
which provides a good quality
replacement dwelling yes um do you agree
agree with me that it is possible to
provide a good quality replacement
dwelling that isn't materially larger
and doesn't have such a significant
impact on the openness of the green belt
well firstly I don't agree with your
premise that this has a significant
adverse impact um quite clearly there
are a number of different schemes to
come that could come forward uh
including a smaller dwelling I think you
have to recognize however that has been
noted in the committee report we've got
quite a modest dwelling at the moment uh
which doesn't meet family conditions the
applicant has a requirement U to to meet
his family needs and therefore even if
you extended this dwelling you know by
double it's still not necessarily going
to produce something which the applicant
needs for his own family needs and if I
may add the core strategy is quite
specific um that the council will
support uh householders aspirations in
terms of meeting their own family needs
lovely thank you councelor
bars yes we saw a picture from the
parish council with the size of theirs
have you got dra or pictures or of the
proposed house yes well um there was a a
whole series of drawings submitted with
the application and a number of
photographs which um haven't been
displayed um but obviously um what we
have there in the top right corner
looking at it is the front elevation are
you the elevation that you'll see as you
come up the drive from the canal um the
um bottom right uh is the
Western Southwestern elevation I.E so
that is as you go up the
drive the view you'll see from the land
to the right hand side if you could drop
through to the next one please and the
size and bulk of the thing is
substantially greater than well it is
yes I mean it is it is larger than but
whether it's significant to cause harm
that is the question and that's the test
I think as you'll see from those
photographs the height of the dwelling
is natural fact is only slightly higher
than the existing one and that detail is
contained in the committee report thank
you very much are there any other
questions no thank you for those very
good
answers um right okay if we can go to
technical
questions I'm very sorry councelor
Lorton I'd almost forgotten about you
how could I you have five
minutes
uh good evening chairman members um I'm
here in uh in support of this some
excellent planning application uh there
appears really to be no argument as to
the Merit of replacing uh an existing
building of poor quality and
construction architectural form so the
point uh members is at issue is the size
of the replacement dring and its citing
in the green belt uh whilst the office's
report and recommendation is claimed to
be in accordance with our own core
strategy um it admits the sustainab
sustainability issue in the nppf where
there is a presumption to Grant in favor
of a sustainable development and also
within our own policy there is policy
that says that homeowners can extend
their houses to meet their own
individual
needs so let's look at policy policy cs1
looks to secure high quality development
well you can see from the pictures we've
seen that uh this is a striking Oak
frame building that can only be
described as having quality and
appropriate character so it meets policy
cs1 in heaps and it's also policy in the
adopted w w
NDP with regard to sustainability the
construction proposals are highly
sustainable the position is sustainable
in respect of construction the Energy
Efficiency reduced carbons water runoff
and as such fit in well with course
strategy CS2 and CS4 it's also clear
that the development in retention of
pasty land and extensive tree parking
panting encourages biodiversity so this
proposal does exactly that in accordance
with both the nppf and core strategies
CS5 and six the report really boils down
to the size of this dwelling as I said
and it replaces and it's it's replaces
and its impact on the Catal Clause
relating to harm and openness in the
green belt with regard to this due to
the position of the building its design
and particular it's being adjacent to a
significantly bigger agricultural brick
built building this is not on its own in
the middle of nowhere it's right next
door as you can see to some very very
substantial brick
buildings um so it's really as been
argued before it's not
inappropriate in this instance uh
members should take note that the
building does not extend beyond the
existing curtilage of the site the
parking provision that's been discussed
is as per the existing building and the
report mentions an increase in Building
height which is negligible so we have a
proposal for a quality new Farmhouse to
be occupied by a long-standing local
family member uh farming family I
believe the proposal meets all the
relevant objects of the mppf and is of
high quality design and will enhance the
qualities of this special landscape area
I urge then that on this this occasion
members Grant consent for the
application for the following reasons it
has the full support of the parish
council and complies with its
neighborhood development plan it fully
complies with the sustainability
requirements in our core strategy and
the nppf in accordance with cs10 it will
not in my opinion have a material impact
on the landscape the reason being that
it is situated in such a position as not
to be isolated it is next door to some
big buildings the scale and the design
of the development reflect the character
of the area and it's very much in
accordance with policy
cs9 the report has noted concern over
the access Bridge um I can confirm that
there is an alternative access from the
Stratford Road so any concerns members
may have a damage to that structural
building which is listed or that bridge
which is listed um is is negated by the
fact that there is an agricultural
access from statford road which is
currently used by tractors and fairly
heavy heavy machinery so there's no
problem there
therefore contrary to the opinion of the
planning officer it does comply with
policy E10 the special circumstances are
here to as follows the need to replace
the defective dwelling with a character
sustainable Farmhouse appropriate to its
setting and the 780 acres of land
surrounding it its proximity to a
substantial brickbuilt agricultural
buildings do allow scope for a larger
dwelling than it replaces which is
perfectly in scale and therefore has no
harmful effect to the openness and
character of the green belt so it does
accord with policy cs10 in this instance
so my conclusion and hopefully yours
will agree that contrary to the
officer's report this fine Farmhouse
does comply with various policies and as
such should be welcomed by the committee
thank you chair uh thank you very much
are that any
questions no thank you very much
councelor uh questions for the
offices no uh discussion debate
councelor Giles
um when I read the report I found it to
be very clear um it sets it sets out a
very clear pathway as to why on a on a
number of very strong grounds this is
just not policy compliant and I have to
say I find the comments that we've had
in support of this application have
largely tried to ignore what are the
very clear policy you know what is very
clearly set out in what I think is a
very well reasoned report um it sort of
to to ignore the idea that this house
isn't to say it's not materially larger
is just to defy the statistics and the
figures that are there um it to to to
then Place focus on saying well it's of
high quality design therefore it's okay
um ignores the fact that obviously you
can have a property of high quality
design which is not materially larger
than the property that exists the whole
purpose of this legislation is to say
where where we're in Green Belt and
there is exist an existing building
clearly it makes sense that you can
demolish it and build something which
looks fairly similar to what is already
there but the point is this is green
belt and so the purpose behind this is
to say what we don't want is people
saying right we'll knock it down and
we'll just put anything in its place um
there are clearly absolutely no very
special circumstances so to me it's very
clearly inappropriate development we
then look at what very special
circumstances that there are there are
none and to for us to try to strain to
find them would be um very
that alone those alone are sufficient
enough reason to say absolutely not this
ought to be refused but then we go on to
actually look at the the actual impact
on the Green Boat and again I find it
very well reasoned I think the crucial
paragraphs are on page 53 I think you
know it talks about not just the size of
the dwelling but the glazed design the
spread of the built form it will make it
a prominent feature on the landscape and
we need to be very clear about what this
landscape is it talks about it being
just outside the high high medium
sensitivity it's an open pastoral Valley
scene and we know it's an incredibly
open Royal character I mean if anyone's
been up been up there it's actually a
very unique unique place in the district
it's um it has a a feel to it and
actually I can see to put a building of
that size that is actually quite in
congruous irrespective of whether it's
seen as against other farm buildings I I
think will be very prominent um so
essentially there are there are two
quite strong grounds because it's it's
contrary to policy on the green B but
then it's also actually will have an
impact on the landscape which is
negative so I think I think those
conclusions are flawless and I would
encourage committee to refuse the
application and I propose a refusal uh
thank you very much anyone else K ainson
uh yes chairman I think one expression I
picked up was planning is not in exact
size and this I believe illustrates the
point I believe the agent and the W
member have put forward very valid
circumstan
it does not have a material adverse
impact on the green Bel you have got
neighbors there which are agricultural
buildings of a substantial standard the
issue about parking I find a bit odd
because of the fact it already exists um
I think also the issue about the
fallback position with permitted
development whilst that has not been
reasoned out it exists without any doubt
and it would see from concluding
paragraph on page 51 that the fallback
position if peritter development was
exercized can accommodate this structure
and the structure is not unusual in the
area also when you think about green
belt and it's being precious in our own
policy this committee a few months ago
did actually pass an application in the
green belt for the demolition of one
house and the construction of three all
of which would be dwarfing this now okay
it is policy on infilling but it is
green belt again and I just cannot see
that one can select that and then go to
the other it's not an exact science I
think the case for this application has
been well reasoned its feature and its
structure and its appearance is very
much typical of a number of houses in
the area there is one next door to me
which will probably be slightly larger
than this I just cannot always follow
the rationale here when we had this 30%
issue an application came to
refuse but because of the reason which
the members did then its volume increase
was slightly less than this slightly
145% I think and that went through
because it was thought reasonable as
indeed I believe this is and I hope
members will look upon it that way
rather than take what I term strict
academic intellectual interpretations
which have no practical value at all D
with the experts quite right Council VRE
can you turn your um thing off
please I'm afraid George I disagree with
you on this one it's I can't get over
the the size element of it it's I'm sure
it's very nicely designed mind you know
large family all that stuff but the
reality is there are there are it's a
planning committee and there are
planning very strong planning rules
around green belt and in this instance
this design strikes me as being far too
big for the policy so I'm very happy to
Second councelor Charles's proposal
right we've had a we've had a proposal
in a second uh I'm going to have two
very brief comments one from can bars
yes I went to a seminar on green belt
and the lady said design and materials
is the important thing if this had been
a bit smaller I think we go with it okay
thank you councel Richards I'm not going
to draw it out let's go to the vote okay
uh so we've had a proposal an a seconder
to refuse as recommended all those in
favor of
refusing two three four five six
chairman all those in favor all those
against refusing
all those um
abstaining have we got a couple that are
just not
talking can we can
we atson what are you doing are you
abstaining or
objecting okay okay so you're objecting
councelor Barnes were you abstaining or
were you no he yeah okay are you happy
okay this committee has resolved to um
refuse that
application
uh uh we now have to vote to carry on uh
we've got a couple more or one more two
more to do I propose we vote to carry on
all those in
favor just okay all those against
carrying on
all those abstaining or not doing
anything okay so we're going to carry
on um good so the next
application what's up as long as we've
got one two three four so we can do it
with
five we can do it with five so I want to
go home too so um we are
18246 middle house dragging ton Lane if
we can
hear from
Stuart uh thank you chairman um this is
a full planning application for the uh
demolition of parts of an existing
domestic Ander building uh and the
erection of a three bed dwelling uh on a
smaller footprint of the building to be
demolished uh and the conversion the
retained uh building to be converted
into a garage to serve this proposed
dwelling uh this application site is an
area of open Countryside approximately
800 meters to the northwest of dorington
uh accessed off brington Lane as
illustrated by the black dots on this
plan
here uh this slide shows the uh Redline
application boundary as displayed here
uh in addition to illustrating a grade
two listed uh property brington house uh
filled in red here on the
plan um one can also see a public
RightWay Illustrated here by the Dead
the uh green dotted line uh here we see
a satellite uh area view of the site uh
signified Again by The Red Arrow uh one
can see the largely open Countryside uh
setting of the application sites uh we
now go on the proposals um here we have
a site uh location plan which shows uh
in detail the sent to the applicant's
land ownership uh here signified by the
Blue Line uh including the main dwelling
Meadow house situated here alongside the
red line application
boundary uh here we have the existing
and proposed site layout plan uh one can
see the extent of the existing domestic
ancillary building here um on the
proposed site lout plan this is then
shown to be uh the element here that to
be retained which is the garage um one
can then see the dwelling element
here um one can then also see there is
proposed to be a partial cutting back of
the existing uh hedro elements here to
in an effort to better improve uh
visibility for Ingress and egress to
this
site um here we have the uh proposed
elevations for the dwelling um it's
proposed uh it's proposed to be a one
and a half one and a half stored
property um shallow pitched Gable uh
ended dwelling uh comprising of Timber
boarding and uh facing brick work uh the
roof is supposed to be uh gray zinc uh
with the addition of roof lights and a
small flu on top of the roof also um we
can also see the uh partially alter
building that will be proposed to be
retained which is the garage uh
here here we have then some perspective
imagery of what the dwelling will be
where uh permission to be granted uh
here we see um the glazed recessed
balcony element here which is supposed
to be the front elevation uh fronting
onto brington
Lane um and also the aluminium windows
and doors uh as detailed on the on the
uh elevations um we now look at the site
photos uh here we're standing on
brington Lane pick up on brington road
uh in front of the meadow house property
uh looking southwards at the existing
building and the proposed vehicle access
which is there currently uh one can also
see part of the hedro which we proposed
to be trimmed back uh as part of this uh
submission here we are stood in front of
the building itself um looking
northwestwards here we are stood uh to
the side of the existing building
looking eastwards uh one can see the the
the appearance of this building being as
it was a former agricultural
building um understood to be a for of
chicken ched um here we are stood at the
rear of the building this is the element
that is proposed to be retained as the
garage uh serving the dwelling uh one
can also see the element of the the
boundary treatment the mature trees
which separate the application site with
the listed property further Beyond these
trees here uh and this is just a photo
showing the inside of the uh inside of
the application building proposed to be
demolished um there are no updates chair
uh for this application uh there is a
recommendation to refuse this
application for the reason set out on
pages uh 72 and 73 of your agendas thank
you thank you Stuart uh and we're going
to go to the parish council now in
support Gail Williams from dorsington
Parish
Council you have three minutes and uh I
if you've done this before just press
the button until the red light comes
on and I'll tell you when you've got
half a minute left okay dorsington
Parish Council supports its application
for the following reasons the applicants
consulted extensively with their
neighbors with no concerns being put for
forward to either the applicant or the
parish council throughout the process in
addition to the support from councelor
Peter bonds statutory consultations with
environmental health highways ecology
Waste and Recycling and the CPR resulted
in no objections to this
proposal the application was also
discussed at the well attended parish
council meeting in early October again
with no parishwide concerns concerns
raised regarding the proposals
indeed everyone agreed that it was a
better use of an unattractive building
and that the design and Landscaping
would be visually more
attractive furthermore the parish
council feels that the proposed design
is rural in appearance and not urbanized
as a case officers report
suggests indeed this type of design very
much lends itself to a rural setting
with its ability to take in the
beautiful Vista right in front of it
with the design itself being based on an
award-winning rural project which was
shortlisted in Grand
designs indeed this three bedroom
retirement home has been designed to a
high standard using a variety of
materials to create a wellth thought
through energy efficient build form that
the parish council feels will not in any
way detract from or harm its rural
setting furthermore the other properties
along this part of brington Lane are all
individ idual in design which in essence
promotes brington Lane's appeal from
Meadow house which is a traditional
brick build building to a grade to
listed building a castellated property
and finally to a linear built Bungalow
with its largely glazed front edge again
primarily to take in the breathtaking
Countryside
views in addition brington is a hamlet
in its own right and should not be
confused with the dorsington
Conservation Area which is very specific
area relating to dorsington Village only
this application being clearly outside
that area so I do hope that committee
members will look positively on all that
will be said today the parish feels very
strongly that there is nothing in the
design the look the quality or standards
being put forward that will detract from
its rural setting and indeed the parish
will gain a three-bedroom property in
lie of what could become an unwanted
blot on the landscape thank you thank
you very much indeed uh any questions no
thank you that's great okay we shall now
there are no objectors as just been
stated so we will go on to the
applicants agent uh uh welcome back Jane
kashmore and Mr Donald Lindsay who's the
applicant I believe
thank you just to explain in terms of
timings I'll probably take the first
couple of minutes and Mr Lindsay will
finish off with the rest you happy to do
that on your own without us telling you
anything it go yes
thanks good evening this application
comes before you with support from the
parish council councelor Barns and no
objections from Neighbors the report
cites three reasons for refusal our
address reasons one and two and Mr
Lindsay will address the third reason
first of all the principle of
development since the core strategy was
published the nppf has been updated in
July this year at paragraph 79 of the
mppf an additional circumstance has been
added where new isolated homes in the
countryside are
acceptable this is the subdivision of an
existing residential
dwelling the officer acknowledges in the
reason for refusal that the building the
subject of this application ation has a
lawful ancillary use to Meadow house but
then says subdivision doesn't apply
because it's not part of the dwelling
this seems contradictory if it's not
part of the dwelling what is it part of
the ancillary nature of the building has
been proved through
lde the garden is also gardened to
Meadow house and Mr Lindsay has
submitted a statutary declaration to
testify to this this has not been
acknowledged at all in the officer
report let alone disproved the entire
site is therefore part of meadow house
and the proposal can be considered
subdivision the principle of development
is therefore supported by paragraph 79
of the mppf which is more up to date in
this respect than the core
strategy turning to impact on the
conservation area we disagree with the
officer report the slide on the screen
shows the site is over 800 meters away
from the Conservation Area brington road
is one of three key entry points to the
Village but the slide on the screen
screen is taken from the conservation
area
appraisal this shows main streetcap
views the view is much closer to the
Village as you would expect not 800 M
away added to this the proposal results
in reduced built form on site and the
design has a barn conversion type
appearance there is no need to find
public benefit in The Proposal as the
development simply does not affect the
setting of dorson Conservation
Area thank you during the course of the
application we have submitted amended
plans to address some officer concerns
about design the design is sensitive to
the locality it's been designed by a
local architect is of simple form and
resembles many agricultural conversions
seen across the
district the proposed glazing is
recessed into the building which reduces
impact the report refers to domestic
paraphernalia but the entirety of this
site is already domestic and and of
course the new site would be fully
landscaped I'm not a property developer
I simply want to subdivide my existing
plot in accordance with paragraph 79 of
the nppf to create a home that meets our
needs the development results in visual
enhancement of this Brownfield building
and a large reduction in the fo
footprint and floor space which is
currently on site for domestic use I'm
afraid that's appliation thank
you thank
you any
questions canor VRI Jade would you
accept that with the elevated height
you'd be able to see this in the
conservation area when now I would say
it's quite difficult to see
it in terms of standing looking back
towards a site from the village the
increase in height may be visible but
what the conservation are offic is
concerned is is the apparently the
impact on the setting of The
Conservation Area when you approach The
Village driving past the site and it's
my view that there's such a distance
between that there simply is no impact
on setting particularly when the
conservation area appraisal identifies
Key Street skate
viewpoints okay thank
you no thanks very much
okay
and we will now hear from councelor
Barnes who has five
minutes
okay
um yes I think we'll have the old
building the old shed on if You' like
for a picture uh and the U uh the
location really put it there for the
moment anyway um situation is that uh
this was an agricultural building but
it's not anymore uh in fact it was one
of Felix Dennis's uh
um buying he bought all the land and
everything and it was hadn't been used
for agriculture and it isn't really I
believe legally now an agricultural
building it's an
unsustainable area for
agriculture and uh all the people that
live next door are very happy if you can
see on this picture there is no need for
any Landscaping because Landscaping is
done all the way around all the trees
are already there they've all grown up I
think it would be relevant just to put
the site uh now if you could uh tell
people where we
are or whatever anyway yeah yes you
beong uh along this road are six houses
um and and the first one is the one in
the blue line then the shed that was
with it which is to be the replacement
dwelling then a listed
building um and then two more houses uh
and two more a little bit further on 20
or 30 yards so brington has sort of half
a dozen houses and this is sort of in
the
middle the first application that came
in we didn't like the design simply was
that as far as I was concerned
personally I didn't like it um and I
they withdrew the
idea um as the Clark of the parish C or
the chairman of the parish council said
we had a meeting in the church the
applicant wasn't very happy because I
threw him out and told him I was going
to discuss it with the
public um and the public that were there
which was a cross-section small as you
want but we have to do things properly
the public were there and there was
quite a number of people there agreed
that this design was more in keeping
than the original design which just
looked like a house if you want to put
it that way um so uh we decided uh that
we would support the
application it is in an isolated stot or
one of six houses um and it is for
agriculture and for domestic in an
unsustainable location it is a building
that needs repair the last time it was
used Felix Danish couldn't buy any
peacocks from anywhere so he decided to
breed them himself and that's where he
did it oh uh the other thing I think of
importance in the respective
sustainability is that the school bus
goes by there for the junior school now
there's two children of five in the
village just started there's nine on the
bus so in the respect of going to school
uh the school bu was is going past this
particular site as far as I'm concerned
the design is a lot better than it
was um because it was just like a house
before this fits in got Landscaping all
the way around no need for that I think
it will be enhancement of the area uh
and uh in the respect of the comments
that were made by it was um the
Conservation Area I think that's about
over 800 M away which is not a
sustainable distance uh we have an
application indoors intern at the moment
on a house and I said that I was
concerned about in the conservation area
an extension of materials and the girl
said oh well it doesn't matter really
it's not a listed building so laugh as
you might that that in my eyes is a
significant factor and as far as I'm
concerned although it's in open
Countryside it does have a school bus
it's got all the landscaping around it
it isn't agricultural
supported thank you councelor any
questions no thank you so technical
questions counc Giles I just wondered if
I could have a look at the drawings of
the proposal and in a bit a bit closer
up and a bit more detail uh yes these
ones and it was ones at the top um yeah
we could just zoom in a little bit sorry
sorry apologies just one
second that's correct yeah that
yeah
yes
uh the the balcony element is the one
that will be most visible from the
street scene on brington Lane yes um
yeah
Street uh correct yeah the front door
will be facing I guess where Meadow the
property Meadow house currently is um
okay yeah so
yeah okay any other
questions no so to
debate anybody councelor chares thank
you very
much okay um I think there were overall
I I agree with the officer's report um I
think there are some some quite
important key paragraphs I actually I've
read the um um part about the the
dwelling um whether this is anciliary or
attached and actually the paragraph at
page 68 does does make sense to me um it
says officers reject this View and note
that whilst this building has lawful use
ancillary to the enjoyment of the main
residential dwelling medal house it is
not in a part of the dwelling the barn
sits on land which is separate to the
dwelling and which did not benefit from
from any change of use um so that that
that reasoning strikes me as sound it
strikes me therefore that one would have
to be satisfied that a new house
essentially in this location is
sustainable I think it's quite difficult
to argue that it's a sustainable
location um but actually the reason that
concerns me most is is what's outlined
on page 69 which is I consider that this
proposed Frontage with the prominent
glazed recessed balcony element and the
wide shallow pitched gay Blended
elevation will be visually prominent
from the Street Scene I do not consider
this design to be sensitive to the open
Countryside setting furthermore I do not
consider that the design is well related
to an integrated the existing form of
the settlement it's considered the
proposed dwelling would result in an
urbanizing effect in an area that's
agricultural in nature and in open
Countryside and not of a character of
its immediate surroundings and I think
when I look at that and look at the area
in the photos I I agree with that on a
on a planning judgment point of view I
do actually agree that there I think
there will be some visual impact on the
setting of the conservation era I think
depending on where you're standing
because obviously it's it's going to be
prominent because it's increasing in
height so I think overall I think the
reasons are set out on page
72 um I agree with those and I would um
I propose to refuse it in accordance
with the officer's recommendation thank
you councel
Giles you'll second that um I I will go
to the vote um no I got to say something
uh
I know I don't have to uh I I I don't
particularly agree with the um the
Heritage argument actually I think we're
too far away for it to have a have a
have a have um an effect I I hear what
the parish council and the the member
have said about the design I actually
quite like the design so if it was if it
was going to be there I don't think the
design would count against it if there
was if it was sort of if it could be
there but I think our reason one our
main reason I think for refusal that
it's just it's it's not the subdivision
of an existing dwelling it's the
creation of a new dwelling anyway you
know because it's knocking down um what
is ancillary and creating a new building
so it's not subdivision and I don't
think there is an existing dwelling it's
a it's a it's something associated with
the dwelling so I think our reasoning is
sound and for me it's just reason one
but I I will be voting with you anyway
so if we can go to the vote all those in
favor
of granting
permission refusing sorry let's start
again all those in favor of refusing
permission one two three that's
unanimous chairman okay thank you so we
have refused application
18246 mid
house
um
okay one
left oh gosh no I wasn't going to finish
I just thought Linda might want to go so
the final application tonight
18141 uh land off Langley
Road
Langley
clavan and we're hearing from Charlotte
thank
you
thank you
chairman the site is indicated on the
map by the black circle the application
site is located to the west of clavan
within the open Countryside it is
accessed via Langley
Road this slide shows the application
site edged in red directly to the north
of the site is a recent development of
four dwell
which has not yet been completed the
application site is to be used as padic
asso associated with plots 2 and three a
residential dwelling known as reading
Hurst is located to the west of the site
the site is within the West Midlands
Greenbow as well as the Arden special
landscape area the nearest public right
away is visible to the east of the
site this is an application for full
planning permission for a part
retrospective change in site levels to
the paddock Land in connection with the
adjoining Housing
Development this plan shows the approved
site plan for the four dwellings
approved under application
16393 full and the original ground
levels as shown under application
14007 full the level Contours show a
rising ground levels across the site
from east to
west
this slide shows the finy levels
proposed within the site as well as the
proposed drainage scheme as can be seen
from The Contours the land has been
leveled to the rear of plots two and
three with seeper slopes to either side
of the site a land drain is proposed
across the site fed by
channels to the sides a further drain is
also proposed at the toe of the slope to
the western boundary of the site as
recommended by the ground investigation
specialist
list this slide shows the proposed
section AA which runs south to North
Plot three is visible on the right hand
side this slide shows the section BB
which runs west to east plot three is
shown on the left hand side with plot
two on the right hand side this section
is to the front of the neighboring
property reading
Hurst section c is shown on this slide
which also runs west to east but is
further back within the site and the
rear of the neighboring property it
shows that the ground level would still
fall towards the
east these photos are both taken facing
towards the western boundary of the site
from the rear of the padic land reading
Hurst is visible and the photo on the
top this photo is of the top soil Bund
in the foreground and the existing
contractors compound reading Hurst is
visible in the
background excavation is still to be
carried out to the to level the ground
underneath the compound
area this photo is taken showing the
context of the Bund and compound with
ring Hurst visible in the background
plot three which is under construction
is to the right hand side of the
photo the top photograph is looking
towards the eastern boundary of the site
and the fields Beyond whereas the lower
phot2 is of the rear of the site looking
towards the Open
Fields just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet officer
recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to the conditions
set out on pages 84 and 85 of the agenda
thank
you uh thank you Charlotte uh so we're
going to go
to um the parish council and this is
Simon laon
for clav and Parish Council who are
objecting uh thank you chairman um the
parish council rejected this work which
uh came to our notice as industrial
amounts of top soil were removed by a
fleet of lores through the conservation
area of the village we asked enforcement
and we're very grateful to the uh
department for uh uh before getting the
development stopped sort of halfway
through when we uh considered the
original application for four houses
here the parish council was satisfied
that the development Works would be
contained within the boundaries of an
ugly Brownfield site it was a former
Goods yard but that the original land
attached formerly Pony paddock Land
would remain untouched this is now not
the case and the PC would certainly have
objected to this offsite land shaping
had it been included in the original
application left it is and with further
work to be carried out the council are
concerned about the future stability of
the site and its potential adverse
effect in the neighboring house reading
Hurst the owners are speaking on this
laser with their technical adviser we
did ask the Developers for a full
structural engineer report a report was
offered by a GE of a geotechnical nature
it did not offer any comfort and did not
address erosion slippage and damage to
the neighbor's property and visual
immunity was actually produced by a
qualified not by a qualified engineer
but by an architectural
assistant we find it hard to understand
how effectively moving a natural feature
of the landscape can possibly be
recommended for planning approval added
to this further excavation is applied
for with a sheer drop of just four
meters from Ringer's house this is
madness we urge the committee to
consider the vandalism caused within the
green belt and its effect on the
neighboring immunity in and order its
Enforcement Officers to instruct a total
rear state in statement of this land its
previous natural level at the very least
members before and as part of any
decision it must be stressed that any
geot technical issues must be addressed
and perhaps in this instance perhaps I
might ask for this to be deferred rather
than
granted um the technical issues as
you'll hear are are very important we do
note on the update sheet there has been
some extra technical uh stuff I've just
read it tonight I haven't seen it before
it hasn't been offered and my client or
my my Parish members
um structural engineer hasn't seen it
either another good reason to defer it
so in summary this is a clear and
obvious harm in the green belt and in
such it's contrary to our core strategy
cs10 covering Green Belt cs9 covering
harm to neighbors immunity and finally
if you need another reason to refuse it
the site is in a special landscape area
and the DraStic land alteration to take
away what was a gently sloping Paddock
to now basically a flat Bowling Green is
certainly contrary to policy CS5 and
cs12 thank you chair uh thank you very
much any
questions no thank you uh and we will
now hear from Ian harbon Consulting
engineer and Mr Mrs
day also
objecting hello so you have three
minutes that's the button there right
okay I'm Steven day uh the neighbor and
this is Ian who Ian har who is our
technical consultant who's come along to
answer any questions so I'll far away uh
our main concern is that the work will
destabilize our land and property over
time to understand the implications to
our property we've engaged an
independent technical consultant Ian
harbon to review the retrospective
submissions by Jackson developments
including that from GIS submitted
firstly the gis report offers no Comfort
to us as to the results of the works it
is scaned in detail the pre- and post-
level excavation levels are unclear or
missing and in fact the report includes
no detail for the area that is still
proposed to be excavated there are no
technical details drawings or
specifications provided to describe the
works nor the land retaining measures
that are being proposed there is no
indication that any assessment has been
made of the effect on our adjacent land
due to changes in the water table such
as drying shrinkage cracking and
subsequent slippage and movement caused
by the work Undertaker bearing in mind
this is a clay uh landscape and in fact
this is a crucial point the gis report
actually states that there is a 1% risk
of failure in the land over a 25-year
period this time scale is erroneous as
is is a guide and is used more typically
for earthw works as undertaken for
Highway construction where there are no
immediately neighboring properties a
more valid time frame needs to be
allowed for due to the close proximity
of our neighboring residential property
for example our property could have a
potential life cycle of over 150 years
and what failure rate would be
calculated on that basis quite apart
from the time scale used consider the
implications of the statement there is a
risk of failure there was previously no
risk to our property due to movement or
land slippage but there is now entirely
as a result of the unauthorized works
works as undertaken and proposed this is
absolutely not right and should not be
allowed to happen there have been no
binding guarantees guarantees given to
us and no underwritten assurances or
other insurances offer to mitigate the
increased level of risk we now face by
the to develop his own admission
irrespective of whether the decision is
to complete the Earth removal or
reinstate there will be heavy Earth
moving equipment required either way as
inferred in the Archie wildish letter of
the 24th of October there will be noise
and disturbance if the site is
reinstated similarly should the
remaining Earth be removed the level of
disturbance that we face is greater as a
rem removal will be nearer to our house
the work was ceased by stop order during
the works and prior to the full
extraction of the Earth this has left
the site and the soil at a critical
stage importantly there's a remaining
section of Earth adjacent to the
boundary and immediately alongside our
house and this currently Remains
undisturbed the lack of supporting
technical detail provided by the
developer means we are justifiably very
concerned that our property is at
increased risk if this remaining Earth
is removed 30 seconds the planning
officer's recommendation to Grant will
put our house at greater risk of land
slippage and movement entirely due to
the works undertaken the supply Tech
information is scant and lacking detail
so it would be irresponsible to allow
the remaining Earth to be removed next
to our house to by thereby increasing
the risk of failure we strongly urge
that if a full reinstatement order is
not applied then the remaining section
of Earth should remain undisturbed no
more Earth should be removed from the
site immediately adjacent to our
property this will reduce the risk of
slippage and move movement to our
property if not to our land thank you uh
thank you very
much any questions councilor Giles um
Council Lon has suggested to us that
committee might want to defer this um in
order for further questions to be
answered yes are you able to outline
whether you agree with that and and if
so what further questions do you think
need to be answered what are the crucial
questions that you feel aren't
answered well the The crucial questions
that that haven't been answered firstly
uh are to do and Ian will collect me on
this if I don't get it completely right
um the fact that there's no um obvious
assessment of the impact of the removal
of the soil on the stability of the of
the clay it's a clay based soil it's um
it's been there for millennia
and it's now been Disturbed this the
photographs if you go back to the
photographs you can see uh they
mentioned the bunded uh the bunded land
with the containers on that's still in
place that's a that's the one there if
you zoom in you can see that there's
some workshops there that the that the
the chaps uh use as as storage and so on
but there's about beneath that there's 2
meters of of just over 2 meters of clay
that's been removed and that you know
what effect is that going to have on the
adjacent Clay is it going to dry out I
mean as Ian can answer that probably
better than I can but well if I can just
add to that so effectively there's been
a a large scale excavation immediately
adjacent to the reading Hurst boundary
the in the location of the house the
ground is still present so that ground
hasn't been excavated were it to be
excavated then effectively it's exposing
a 2 meter face of soil um to exposure to
rain which can be controlled through
surface treatment um but also to drying
over a longer period of time and to
longterm um erosion and potential
slippage so prior to excavation there
was n nil risk of that occurring along
the boundary line now there is
excavation and there is proposed to be
further excavation and it is
acknowledged by the applicant's own
expert that that increases the risk of
movement to the r site so there is
acknowledged to be an increase in risk
of movement to Mr and Mrs day's
property okay uh so councelor bars
first
sorry what you're basically saying is
that the
sub the top soil protects the subsoil
the top soil has been taken away so the
subsoil is now vulnerable
as a farmer I'm talking yeah yeah do you
understand so therefore as I
say the rain will have more of an effect
or less of an effect the dryness because
there's no cover there's no protection
from the
subsur oh per I'm not explaining myself
I think we agree with that and if I can
jump in again sorry only because this is
very close to my heart um the fact that
that landscape Cape hadn't been moved
for such a long time there was a
stability there we haven't had any
movement but you know the fact that it's
now taken and drainage is proposed
there's no assessment of what that's
going to do in terms of drawing moisture
out of the clay and whether with the you
know it's going to drve more crack and
and therefore cause problems okay that's
that's that's good we've kind of doubled
that over uh CC Richards great um so you
you talking about risk and there was
Zero risk before and that acknowledge
there is risk now in your professional
opinion what is that risk how high is
that
risk there is an increased risk I think
the applicant's um expert suggests that
um risk is measured over time periods so
he he has suggested a one in 25 I think
it might be 30 year return period so
he's suggesting there's an an increase
of or there's a risk of 1% failure in a
30-year time frame but when you're
looking at a which is fine for a
Motorway embankment which is the
criteria that's be that he has used for
that assessment um but it isn't fine
when there's a property in close
proximity because a property would be
expected to have a longer um return
period of time frame over which you
would expect there to be little risk so
that assessment has not been made yet
and that's my point I think there's been
insufficient assessment of the risk of
damage to the property over the long
term okay thank
you so there's two there's two different
methods in which to uh assess this risk
the method has been used has been for
Motorway backs the method you think
should be used hasn't been applied uh
there's not a specific method it's not
the method it's the period over which
one might consider there to the the the
the damaged period
um for so effectively let me put it
another way effectively he's saying that
in a 30-year period there's a 1%
increase in Risk but over a longer
period of time there's therefore an
increased percentage in risk and one
would normally consider a longer period
of time for a
property okay thank you any other
questions no thank you very much
okay
right and you're not speaking are you no
so we can go to uh we can go
to gosh Liz I'm terribly sorry do come
up do come up you have a whole six
minutes no no no no no no no we're not
so Liz Nicholson hello again hello agent
and Mr Phil Sanger yes hello the good
news was I wasn't going to talk at all
but unfortunately I think I'm going to
have to pick a few points um but first
Phil just wants to introduce himself and
and explain a little bit of what's going
on on this
site um so I'm Phil suer um my wife and
I are moving into plot three which you
may have seen uh which is the house
directly adjacent to Mr and Mrs day's
house reading Hurst um to provide you
with a little bit of background um we've
got very strong links to clavon my
wife's parents will be our neighbors on
the other side of the development and we
were married in St Michael's Church just
down the road fundamentally we're moving
to clavon because of those links and
because we think it' be a great place to
bring up our two young kids the reason
I'm telling you all this is because
we're not some faceless developer who
doesn't really care about the
neighborhood or the Village um we want
to make clev an on new home and it's
therefore not really in our interest to
undertake any work which would be
destructive to the Village or the house
or the
surroundings um the Crux of the matter
is this we've bought a paddock and we'd
like to make it suitable for use as a
paddock in our view uh this involves
making it more level and leveling out
the top soil in particular and that's
essentially all we're
proposing um as you can see from the
paperwork we've had both a structural
engineer and a geotechnical experts
survey the works and theyve both
confirmed that our plans adequately deal
with drainage and the risk of erosion
and slippage is
negligible on a more personal note we
would not be undertaking the works if we
thought for a second that it would cause
a problem with our new home which is
afterward much closer to what we're
proposing than ring Hurst
is um on a final note um as we're aware
as much as Mr and Mrs day are that
should these Works cause any problems
we'll only be a stone store away we're
going to be neighbors after all um and
that's all I have to say and I'll hand
over to
Liz I think I do just need to pick up on
a few points that were made by the
parish council um and by Mr day and and
Mr harbon um in terms of what the parish
council said uh it isn't an
architectural assistant who has provided
the responses on on our behalf you know
you've got the credentials of the geote
technical expert in your update sheet
it's somebody with 40 years experience
in this field um I think the other point
I wanted to pick up with the parish
council was there was talk it was quite
emotive about a sheer drop of four
meters and hopefully you've seen from
the photographs that is not what has
happened on this
site in terms of harms of green belt and
special landscape that's obviously a
planning judgment and that's for
yourselves to make tonight but the
officer report is clear on those that
there there is no harm to
either in terms of you've heard all this
engineering stuff I'm not an engineer
I'm not going to pretend to be one it
used to be very helpful years ago in
ppg-14 which said that you get an
Engineers report and you take it at face
value is it a planning issue it's in the
National planning policy guidance but at
what point do you stop if you defer this
for other information our engineer will
say something their engineer will say
something where does it end and at some
point you need to make a judgment as to
a is it the key planning issue and B
which advice do you go with I would say
the key issues here are impact on
landscape impact on green belt and
special landscape
area in all those
regards this is an acceptable
development there are very limited if
any public views The Works have yet to
be finished which you've heard when the
top soil is spread there really isn't
going to the impact Act is is
negligible and as I say in terms of
engineering I'm not an engineer but
we've provided the expert with the
evidence to to give you and that is in
um both in the main report and in the
update sheet but we're happy to answer
any questions that you have thank you
very much are there any
questions uh councelor
Gils um I just wondered what the reasons
were for the retrospective nature of the
application how that came
about I think it was before my
involvement and I think maybe there was
just a little bit of um confusion or a
misunderstanding and it was um believed
that this didn't require planning
permission it was it was simply a
mistake and as soon as enforcement came
out Works have stopped and they've
stopped for what six or seven months now
is it yeah so so the works have not
carried
on okay n other thank you very much okay
and we can go now to any technical
questions
none okay to
debate councelor bars thank you I'm bit
concerned about this Mr chairman in the
respect that we had a a building site in
wford where the ecology people found
some bones and all sorts of things um um
and basically the top soil protects the
subsoil in other words the subsoil is
moved
substantially uh if it's to the weather
so as far as I'm concerned I I
understand the concern of the objectives
and I'm not exactly sure what the ward
member wanted but I I I I can't go along
with Grant at the moment okay thank you
councelor Richards the W members over
here by the way par counselor I thought
you were going to speak as a person
anyway councelor oh sorry I um I'd like
I didn't mean to inter I'd like to put
it to the committee to I'd see what
their reaction is to this it's next to
impossible to understand the um
uh the plane of the land that we're
looking at from a photo you can't tell
how steep a slope is would the committee
be minded to have a site visit to fully
see and understand the scale of the of
what's been proposed here how deep this
thing's being uh flattened to and how
close it is to the properties okay
councelor chares um I agree and I'd
support that proposal I was going to ask
actually and I meant to ask during
questions whether there any photos of um
how the site looked previously because I
think one thing that's important is to
try to understand what it looked like
what's been done what's the difference
in in in Impact but I don't know whether
those photos are available
tonight unfortunately we haven't got
those photos available well I think that
would strengthen my um view that I think
we ought to have a site visit I think
that information is
complicated um and I think it would be
you know and actually what whichever way
we decide it it's it's important to both
both the applicant and the objectors
okay councelor
VRI uh I'd agree with the concept of
side visit the only additional point I
put out there and I welcome comments on
it is is whether the reality is there is
a gap between both parties at the moment
and whether in fact we should use that
time ahead of a site visit to actually
suggest there should also be further
analysis of the impact of the
groundworks because you I take this's
point you know there comes a point where
you got to say enough evidence is enough
but it just strikes me that going to be
neighbors that Gap is probably rather
too large at the moment and you might
want to decide to do it and whether we
we add that to the site visit or not I
will I will defer to whether other thing
a good idea or not I think the council
reads my mind partially the site visit
to fully understand the scale of what's
been proposed and and the proximity to
properties uh but also it does give an
opportunity for the uh analysis to be
done and for actually for it to be made
easier for us to understand because
we're not geologists and Engineers that
sounds like a very good s a proposal
right and and a seconder from Council
chars Okay so all those in favor of a uh
site
visit okay thank
you uh all those
against
abstaining okay good so we've resolved
to to do
that uh as there's no
other no urg bu no urgent business we'll
finish the meeting
there thank you and what about sorting
out the site
visit yeah K Richards we got a good date
for a site
visit
yeah